ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING
TO GO GET TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED- THANK YOU THIS ONE FOR-
COMING SO EARLY YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TODAY'S
MEETING OF ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
READING TAX I WANT TO REMIND
INDIVIDUALS THAT FOR THIS AND
FUTURE HEARINGS TESTIMONY WILL
pNO LONGER USING MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE WE ARE HOWEVER
ACCEPTING- WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL. ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE FOR THE BILLS TAKEN UP
TODAY WE WILL TAKE NO MORE THAN
TWO PRIMARY WITNESS IS IN
SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR WITH
CONCERNS THESE WITNESSES- WILL
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TO PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY. NOW
FOR A BRIEF HOUSEKEEPING KEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US HAS BEEN REPLACED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO FOR
THIS HEARING ONLY IN ADDITION
DECEMBRIE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
HAS BEEN REPLACED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON FOR THIS HEARING
ALSO AND WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
THINGS SLIGHTLY OUT OF ORDER
BECAUSE AS SOON AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE WILL GO AHEAD AND TO
WHEN WE'RE DONE WITH ITEMS ONE
TWO AND THREE WE WILL TAKE OF.
TAKE UP ITEMS- NINE AND. TEN AND
MISTER CHOI. YOU ARE PRESENTS
AND WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND HOPEFULLY WE
WILL. GET A FEW MORE MEMBERS AND
WILL BE ABLE TO- START VOTING
THANK THEIR- FOR GIVING ME THE
HONOR OF OFFICE- PERSON TO
PRESENT MY BE A- AND ALL THE
MEMBERS UP. GOOD TO SEE YOU. AB. EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE OR THE
REQUIRE A TAX- DEFAULTED THE
PROPERTY BE OFFERED FOR SALE BY
AUCTION BEFORE BEING OFFERED TO
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOR
PURCHASE. THIS BILL ALL. WILL
ALLOW OWNERS SO WHO ARE LOSING
THEIR PROPERTY BECAUSE OF-
UNPAID TAXES THE CHANCELLOR TO
RECOVER ANY EQUITY THEY HAVE IN
THE HOME. THERE IS SOME. EIGHT
WITNESSES WEAKNESS- IN
CALIFORNIA SO LAW THAT ALLOWS
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES SO TO SIMPLY
SALAS THE SEAS THAT TAXES ARE
THE LINK WITH DELINQUENT THE
PROPERTY TO OTHER GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES SO ALL PUBLIC INTEREST
GROUPS ARE. FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSING. IN THIS CASE IS UP NO
ACCESS TO PROCEEDS ARE
GENERATED- ALSO THE FORMER OWNER
RECEIVES P NO COMPENSATION
REGARDLESS OF- HOW MUCH EQUITY
WAS UP IN THE HOME- I HOPE BUT I
HAVE- TO SUPPORT WITNESSES- JOSH
PORK WITH THE PACIFIC THAT LEGAL
FOUNDATION AND THE SCOTT.
KAUFMAN WITH THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
DOCTOR CHOI- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. PRIMARY WITNESSES INCH
SUPPORT PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON- HELLO EVERYONE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR IRWIN AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION MY NAME IS JOSH WILL
PULL AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
THE PACIFIC LEGAL FOUNDATION-
PLF IS THE NATION'S OLDEST AND
MOST SUCCESSFUL FREEDOM BASED
LEGAL ORGANIZATION- IN THE
UNITED STATES AND WE'RE
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS FROM
GOVERNMENT OVERREACH THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO ADDRESS
THE EGREGIOUS PRACTICE WE'VE
LABELED HOME EQUITY THEFT AND
ALLOW ME TO TESTIFY ON THE
ISSUE. IN THE U. S. ABOUT A
DOZEN STATES ALLOW TAXING AGENCY
OR PRIVATE TAX LIEN INVESTOR TO
FORECLOSE ON A TAX DEFAULTED
PROPERTY AND TAKE ABSOLUTE TITLE
REGARDLESS OF THE AMOUNT OF THE
TAX DAY AND THE AMOUNT OF THE
VALUE OF THE PROPERTY. THIS IS
RESULTED AND A AN APPALLING LOSS
OF HOMES AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF PROPERTY EQUITY BEYOND
THE GRIEVOUS COST THE TAXPAYERS
EQUITY THEFT IS ALSO
UNCONSTITUTIONAL EQUITY THE
FINANCIAL INTEREST A PERSON HAS
IN THEIR PROPERTY AFTER
SATISFYING ALL DEBTS IS AS MUCH
A FORMER PROPERTY AS LAND OR
BUILDINGS EQUITY REPRESENTS HOW
MUCH A PERSON HAS INVESTED IN
THE PROPERTY AND ACCOUNTS FOR
THE VAST MAJORITY OF WEALTH HELD
BY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE. BECAUSE
EQUITY IS A RECOGNIZED PROPERTY
INTEREST THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
DICTATES THAT IT CANNOT BE TAKEN
FOR PUBLIC USE THAT INCLUDES
TAXATION WITHOUT JUST
COMPENSATION TO THE OWNER
ULTIMATELY WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
TAKES MORE THAN IT'S OWED AND
MUST PAY THE FORMER OWNER FOR
THE EXCESS PROPERTY VALUE OR
SELL THE PROPERTY TO THE HIGHEST
BIDDER IN RETURN THE EXCESS
PROCEEDS TO THE FORMER- OWNER.
THAT OBLIGATION IS AS OLD AS THE
MAGNA CARTA. AND FAILURE TO
SATISFY THAT OBLIGATION IS A
VIOLATION OF THE CONSTITUTION.
TO ITS CREDIT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PROTECTS EQUITY IN
ORDINARY TAX SALES UNDER CHAPTER
SEVEN OF THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE COUNTIES MAY PUT
TAX DEFAULTED PROPERTY UP FOR
AUCTION. TO THE HIGHEST BIDDER
IN ANY MONEY RECEIVED IN EXCESS
OF THE TAX DEBT AND ITS
STATUTORY INTEREST AND FEES- IS
THEN RETURNED TO. THAT PEOPLE
WHO HOLD INTEREST IN THE
PROPERTY INCLUDING THE PROPERTY
OWNER. IN THESE CASES THE VALUE
OF THE PROPERTY IS PRESERVED AND
THE CONSTITUTION IS SATISFIED
HOWEVER THERE IS. A LOOPHOLE IN
THE REVENUE AND TAXATION COKE%
CHAPTER EIGHT ALLOWS A
GOVERNMENT BODY OR PUBLIC
INTEREST GROUP DEVELOPING LOW
INCOME HOUSING. TO JUST SKIP THE
PUBLIC AUCTION AND PURCHASE THE
PROPERTY OUT RIGHT FOR A
MINIMUM- SEE. NO EXCESS PROCEEDS
RATED AND THE FORMER OWNER HASNO RIGHT TO REQUEST THE
REMAINING EQUITY VALUE IS JUST
COMPENSATION. THIS IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. OF COURSE TAX
COLLECTION IS AN IMPORTANT
FUNCTION OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. COUNTIES RELY ON
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES TO OPERATE
AND CANNOT BE LEFT WITHOUT
RECOURSE WHEN PEOPLE FAIL TO PAY
THEIR DEBTS. HOWEVERTHE
COLLECTION MECHANISM SHOULD NOT
ALLOW THE GOVERNMENT TO TAKE.
AND KEEP MORE THAN WHAT'S OWED
IN ANY OTHER CONTEXT THAT WOULD
BE CALLED AFTER. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SEIZE EQUITY TO
SATISFY SMALLER TAX DEBTS ARE
PLAYING WITH FIRE BECAUSE WHEN
COURTS GET INVOLVED THEY'LL
LIKELY HAVE TO PAY BACK. THE
EQUITY VALUE THAT WAS TAKEN. AND
TO BE CLEAR CLOSING THE CHAPTER
EIGHT LOOPHOLE. LEGISLATIVELY
WOULD NOT SUBJECT COUNTIES TO
ADDITIONAL LIABILITY IN FACT IT
WOULD DO THE OPPOSITE. BY
CURBING FUTURE WRONGS AND
PROTECTING COUNTIES FROM
ADDITIONAL LIABILITY. IT WOULD
ONLY HAVE A MINIMAL IMPACT ON
COUNTY OFFICIALS BECAUSE THE
DEFAULT MECHANISM IS ALREADY A
SALE. AT AN AUCTION TO THE
HIGHEST BIDDER AND THE RETURN OF
PROCEEDS TO THOSE WITH AN
INTEREST IN THE PROPERTY.
ULTIMATELY BY ELIMINATING EQUITY
THEFT ALL PARTIES INCLUDING THE
TAXPAYERS AND THE TAXING
AGENCIES ARE MADE WHOLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS. RIGHT TO US THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURERS AND TAX COLLECTORS
THERE IN SUPPORT OF THE SPIRIT
OF THE BILL AND WE DON'T SEE
THIS HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA- THE
CONCERN THAT THEY HAVE RAISED-
SO WE SUPPORT THE CONCEPT AND
THE- FRANKLY ALREADY COMPLY WITH
THE SPIRIT SO. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY.
AND AS THE PRIMARY YOUR SCOTT
THE WAY YEAH RIGHT THE LATE SO.
HEY WE HAVE TWO MINUTES. TO MAKE
IT BETTER- AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
NINE CLOSE THE LOOP ON
CALIFORNIA'S TACTICAL THE
PROPERTY SALES CONSTITUTIONAL
TAKING THANK YOU. WITHOUT JUST
COMPENSATION OF SEIZE TAX TO
INCOME PROPERTY WHEN IT IS SOLD
TO OTHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES OR
PUBLIC INTEREST GROUPS WERE
GALLO INCOME HOUSING. CHAPTER
EIGHT APART SIX OF DIVISION ONE
COMPANY TAXATION REVENUE CODE
ALLOWS PUBLIC AGENCIES TAX
AGENCIES AN ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. TO ENTER INTO
AGREEMENT TO PURCHASE TACTICAL
THE PROPERTY BY SUBMIT YOUR
REQUEST FOR PURCHASE OR
OBJECTING TO THE SALE OF
PROPERTY SCHEDULE FOR PUBLIC AND
OR SEALED AUCTIONS. IN THESE
CASES NO EXCESS PROCEEDS ARE
GENERATED SO THE FORMER OWNER
RECEIVES NO COMPENSATION
REGARDLESS OF EQUITY. AB FIVE
THREE NINE WOULD ENSURE THAT
PROPERTY OWNERS ARE COMPENSATED
FOR THEIR SEIZE PROPERTY BY
REQUIRING THESE PROPERTIES.
FIRST BE OFFERED FOR SALE UNDER
THE PROVISIONS OF CHAPTER SEVEN.
TWO GREAT ATTENTION THAT THEY
WOULD BE AUCTIONED TO THE
HIGHEST BIDDER AND THE PROCEEDS
RETURNED. THE FORMER PROPERTY
OWNERS AS REQUIRED BY THE
CONSTITUTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND DO WE HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORE
SO I DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND- THE
CHAPTER EIGHT NOW. RIGHT NOW WE
ALLOW A NONPROFIT TO BID ON A
PROPERTY. DOES THE PERSON WHO
OWNS THE PROPERTY HAVE TO ACCEPT
THE BILL FROM THE NONPROFIT. S.
THANK YOU THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COURT- UNDER CHAPTER
EIGHT THE PROPERTY OWNER HAS NO
SAY WHATSOEVER IN WHETHER THAT
THE BID IS ACCEPTED- IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU MEAN- IF I NONPROFIT
PARTICIPATES UNDER CHAPTER SEVEN
AND- AUCTION TO THE HIGHEST
BIDDER. THEN THE PROCEEDS ARE
THEN DISTRIBUTED TO THOSE WHO
HAVE A REMAINING INTEREST IN THE
PROPERTY INCLUDING THE ORIGINAL
OWNER AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW
CHAPTER EIGHT DOES NOT ALLOW THE
OWNER TO HAVE ANY REMAINING
INTEREST. A POST SALE. SO WITH
FIVE IF THE TAX BILL IS TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THEY'RE
SELLING THE HOUSE FOR FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. FIT THE PERSON
DOESN'T GET FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND BACK. SO UNDER THE
CHAPTER SEVEN OPTION IF THAT'S
THE CONTEXT OF THE SALE THEN YES
IF IT'S- SALE UNDER CHAPTER
EIGHT THEN NO NO YOU DON'T GET
ANY MONEY AT ALL THE- THE
ORIGINAL PROPERTY ARE GETS
NOTHING. THAT CORRECT STAFF
COULD I ASK THE CHAIR TO ASK
STAFF. THIS DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT.
THANK YOU DR CORK- IN THE
CONTEXT OF A CHAPTER EIGHT SALE-
NO WITH THE PROPERTY OWNER DOES
NOT GET ANY EXCESS PROCEEDS
RETURNED HOWEVER THAT IS BECAUSE
THE PROPERTY IS ONLY OFFERED FOR
A MINIMUM BID AMOUNT WHICH IS
UNDER LAW THE- TAXES FEES
ASSESSMENTS AND PENALTIES AND
ANY COP GENERALLY SPEAKING
COSTS- TO REIMBURSE THE COUNTY
FOR CONDUCTING THE SALE. HARM SO
AGAIN IF IT TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR PROPERTY. THEN
THE NONPROFIT JUST PAGE TEN
THOUSAND IF THAT'S WHAT'S OWED.
CORRECT BUT AS MISS LANG POINTED
OUT THIS THE- LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS DON'T ENGAGE IN
THAT PRACTICE THAT I CAN BELIEVE
THAT. OKAY THANK YOU MY PLEASURE. I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THIS
BILL WAS PROMPTED BY A-
MICHIGAN'S SUPREME COURT
DECISION INTERPRETING MICHIGAN
LAW AND THEIR LIFE IS A LITTLE
BIT MORE BROAD WHEN IT COMES TO
TAKING HOW DOES THIS- APPLY TO
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION- CHAIR
IRWIN SO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION INTERPRETS THE
FIFTH AMENDMENT. SO EXCUSE ME
THE CALIFORNIA'S ANALOG TO THE
FIFTH AMENDMENT SIMILAR
SIMILARLY TO FEDERAL LAW. AND
IT'S OUR VIEW THAT UNDER FEDERAL
LAW- EQUITY IS RECOGNIZED AS A
DISTINCT PROPERTY INTERESTS AND
IS THEREFORE PROTECTED FROM
UNCONSTITUTIONAL TAKINGS-
THERE'S NOTHING IN CALIFORNIA
PRESIDENT THAT I'M AWARE OF THAT
WOULD TAKE A- I GUESS UNLESS
PROTECTIVE VIEW. OF EQUITY THEN
NOT THE FEDERAL COURTS TO. ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS- I
THINK IT'S ALL AS- DR COURT DID
ASK STAFF- WHO'S WRITTEN IF IT
IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE CHAIR- SO
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LITTLE
CONCERN AS I WAS REVIEWING THIS
BILL THAT THERE WAS. THAT THE
WAY THAT IT WOULD. DEAL WITH
THE- THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN THIS
AND A BILL THAT WE ARE NOT WE
HAVEN'T HEARD YET TODAY- BY MS
WAX- ARE THEY IN CONFLICT WITH
ONE ANOTHER OR THEY BOTH WITH
THE BOTH- HOW WOULD THAT PLAY
OUT OF. THEY BOTH BECAME LAW. IT
WITHOUT HEARING THE OTHER BILL
YET WELL WE'LL WAIT FOR THAT
LATER. I'M SORRY MR THE ARE YOU
ASKING ME ARE YOU ASKING DANCER
NOW OUR BULLETIN NO YEAH SO I
JUST I KNOW MISS WHICH WILL HAVE
A CHANCE TO PRESENT THE BILL
LATER IS WHAT I'M SAYING BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR- ABOUT AYE.
BECAUSE PERHAPS. I GUESS WHAT
I'M SAYING IS MAYBE I WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR BOTH BILLS BEFORE I
CONSIDER VOTING FOR EITHER OF
THE BILLS- BUT I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO HEAR. FROM FROM THE ABOUT
THAT. D. E. S. V. BILLS WOULD
WORK AT COUNTER PURPOSES AS THE-
THE OTHER BILL- AB TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- IS AN EXPANSION OF THE
CHAPTER EIGHT. TAX SALE PROCESS
AND TIS WOULD THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE A CHAPTER SEVEN SALE TO
OCCUR BEFORE CHAPTER EIGHT. SO
THEY WERE IN A PRETTY WEAK SAUCE
CHAPTER SEVEN IF CHAPTER SEVEN
CELL NOT SUCCESSFUL MANAGER
CREATE. A CELL WOULD TAKE PLACE
THEY WOULD REQUIRE THAT CHAPTER
SEVEN BE CONDUCTED BEFORE
CHAPTER RETAILERS TO CLOSE OKAY
AND IF THERE IS NO INTEREST ONLY
THEN COULD CHAPTER EIGHT SALE
TAKE PLACE IN IN THE- SO THAT WE
HAVE NOT YET HEARD FROM. HER
YET. HOW HOUSE CHAPTER EIGHT
EXPANDED IN THAT IT WOULD BE-
COUNTER TO- ALLOWING WOULD JUST
SIT BE THE FIRST SALE IN PLACE
ESSENTIALLY. NO SIR IT JUST
SIMPLY EXPANDS THE EXISTING IT
EXPANDS ELIGIBLE USES UNDER THE
EXISTING CHAPTER A PROCESS. OKAY
I THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE- FIRST
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE GOING TO
- PLEASE- HAVE THE SECRETARY TO
THE ROLL CALL IRWIN. HERE WHEN
HERE GREAT GRAYSON. LEVINE MAYES
. CALDERON YOUR NORRIS QUIRK
HERE SANTIAGO SEYARTO- RIGHT WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO OF WE WILL OF.
BE ABLE TO TAKE A VOTE- R. OF MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE TWO
BILLS ARE IN CONFLICT BECAUSE
ONE IS AN EXPANSION OF CHAPTER
EIGHT. AND TO THE OTHER REALLY
REDUCES THE ABILITY TO USE
CHAPTER EIGHT SO. I WHAT I WOULD
SUGGEST IS AS FOR PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO HEAR BOTH BILLS TO JUST
NOT FELT RIGHT NOW. AND THEN YOU
CAN ADD YOU CAN ADD ON LATER-
THE MY RECOMMENDATION IS A NON
VOTE. I'M PERSONALLY I'M GONNA
BE A NO VOTE BECAUSE I AM
SUPPORTING- MS WICKS IS BILL BUT
I'VE- IF WE I'M LEAVING IT UP TO
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO DO
WHAT THEY WANT AND IF THEY'RE
NOT CLEAR UNTIL THEY'VE HEARD
THE OTHER TESTIMONY. I JUST FEEL
FREE TO LAY OFF RIGHT NOW. THAT
WORK RIGHT OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER CHOI. THANK YOU
THIS ITSELF- VERY- SIMPLER IN
CONCEPT THE THIS KIND OF
SITUATION CAN HAPPEN TO ALL OF
US ALL PROPERTY OWNERS SO UNFAIR
IN OUR OCTOBER ISSUE- SO MOST
PEOPLE DO NOT INTENTIONALLY
FAIL. TO PAY THEIR TAXES PEOPLE
MAY MISCALCULATE THE PROJECT SIX
PART HAVE UNEXPECTED THE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP- AS THE-
ESTATES ARE ARE IN LIMBO AND
LYFT ARE SIMPLY- THINGS- JUST TO
HAPPEN. A. B. EIGHTEEN THIRTY
NINE ORDER- PUT AN END TO HOME
EQUITIES STAFFED IN CALIFORNIA
BY PREVENTING A PUBLIC AGENCY
TAXING AGENCY AND A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION FROM TAKING AN
ENTIRE PROPERTY ALONG WITH THE
HOMEOWNER SO EQUITY THAT WE HAVE
BUILT. A MAJOR- SUPPORTERS OF
THE BILL ALSO HOW THE JOB IS TO
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION PACIFIC
CARDIGAN FOUNDATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WILL
COUNTY. TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR'S AS WELL. SO I HOPE
THAT THE ONE- YOU HAVE A QUORUM
AND- OR YOU HAVE DONE MORE
RESEARCH I WOULD ASK DO YOU VOTE
I ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI-
DO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO- DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE A SECOND
. RIGHT SO WE WILL FALLS YOU'LL
SECOND IT OKAY ALL RIGHT AND-
CAN YOU PLEASE TAKE PHùMISSILES
ARE ON AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN NO IRWIN
NOW WHEN. WHEN ON A GRAY GRAYSON
. GRAYSON NOT VOTING. LEVINE
LEVINE NOT VOTING MAYES MAYES
NOT VOTING. CALDERON
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS NO. QUIRK ARE NOT VOTING FOR NOW
CORRECT NOT LOADING SANTIAGO
SEYARTO IT'S LOCAL IT HAS ONE
OKAY- THAT BILL IS ON CALL AND-
WE ARE GOING TO GO AGAIN
SLIGHTLY OUT OF ORDER AND HAVING
HIS WEEKS COME UP NEXT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GENTLEMAN.
OF THE- THIS WEBSITE I THINK YOU
YOU- HEARD THE DISCUSSION OF WE
DO- THE COMMITTEE DOES THINK
THAT THE TWO BILLS ARE IN
CONFLICT- IF YOU COULD- IF I
DON'T KNOW IF IN YOUR TALKING
POINTS YOU WERE GOING TO ADDRESS
THE CHAPTER SEVEN IN CHAPTER
EIGHT OF THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
BUT- A LOT OF MEMBERS ARE
STAYING OFF UNTIL THEY HEAR
THOSE BILLS. OKAY- THANK YOU I
NEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I DIDN'T
HEAR THE WHOLE CONVERSATION OR
I'M NOT GONNA HAVE A TOUGH LADY
WITH THE PREVIOUS BILL BUT I
CAN. GLADLY AND WILLINGLY
HAPPILY PRESENT. MY BILL- I WANT
TO THANK AT TERROR IRWIN IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITY
PERCENT TWENTY AB TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WE ALL KNOW THAT THE STATE
IS FACING A HOUSING CRISIS AND
TOO MANY FAMILIES STRUGGLE TO
FIND A SAFE AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
CALL HOME. ONE EXISTING STRATEGY
TO EXPAND THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS THE
CHAPTER EIGHT TAX SALE PROCESS.
THE CHAPTER EIGHT PROCESS GIVES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND NONPROFIT
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS THE
OPPORTUNITY OPTION TO BUY TAX
DEFAULT PROPERTIES BEFORE THEY
ARE SOLD AT PUBLIC AUCTION. IF
THEY WILL BE USED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OR TO PROVIDE OTHER
PUBLIC BENEFITS. THIS BILL
UPDATE CHAPTER EIGHT TAX DEFAULT
PROPERTY SALES PROCESS TO MAKE
IT EASIER TO CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. FIRST IT REQUIRES
COUNTY TAX COLLECTOR'S AT THE
FIRST REQUIRES TANEY. IT
REQUIRES COUNTY TAX COLLECTOR
WEBSITES TO INCLUDE CLEAR
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW NONPROFITS
AND OTHER ENTITIES. CAN OBTAIN
THE LIST OF DEFAULT PROPERTIES
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO BE SOLD AT
PUBLIC OPTION. IN ORDER TO GET
BETTER DATA ON CHAPTER EIGHT
SALES THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES.
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
TO REPORT ANNUALLY ON THE NUMBER
OF CHAPTER EIGHT. TAX SALES THAT
OCCUR EACH YEAR. AND FINALLY THE
BILL CREATES ADVISORY GROUP IN
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
INCREASE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION. THROUGH CHAPTER
EIGHT SALES THERE WHILE BE
WORKING TO FIND A MORE
APPROPRIATE ENTITY TO HOST THE
ADVISORY GROUP AFTER THIS BILL
PASSES OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD HAVE PASSED TODAY. I WILL
ALSO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE THE
STAKEHOLDERS GOING FORWARD TO
ADDRESS ANY. CONCERNS WITH A
BILL THIS IS AN AUTHOR SPONSORED. MEASURE AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES. OKAY SO. DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AGAIN
MADAM CHAIR AS YOU COULD TELL
WE'VE BEEN KIND OF STUCK IT'S
BEEN A CHALLENGING COUPLE MONTHS
LEADING UP TO THIS I WANTED TO
THINK THIS THAT'S THE ONLY WOMAN
STAFF FOR HELPING US THROUGH
THIS AND I'M REGRETTABLY THE
TREASURE TECH SECTORS ARE STILL
POSED AS FUNDAMENTALLY THERE'S A
BELIEF AMONG THE MAJORITY OF THE
MEMBERS THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
ADD TO THE STATUTE IN A WAY THAT
SEPARATES PEOPLE FROM THEIR
PROPERTY FOR FASTER AND
ACCELERATE THE WAYS AND USES
FOR. THE GOVERNMENT TO DO THAT-
AND DOT PART SEEMS LIKE WE CAN'T
GET OVER IT BUT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO PROVIDE SUBSTANTIVE
FEEDBACK TO THE AUTHOR IN THE
MEAN TIME TO MAKE SURE IT PASSES
IT IT ACTUALLY WILL WORK ON THE
GROUND FOR US AND A COUPLE OF
THINGS I WANTED TO OBSERVE TO
YOU WHEN A PROPERTY GOES TO TAX
BILL IF IT'S RESIDENTIAL
MINIMALLY IT'S BEEN FIVE YEARS
THAT A PROPERTY OWNER HAS NOT
PAID THEIR PROPERTY TAXES THAT'S
WHEN IT BECOMES DEFAULT IN
ELIGIBLE. AND BEFORE WE CAN TAKE
IT TO TAX SALE WERE KNOCKING ON
THEIR DOOR WE SENT MULTIPLE
CERTIFIED MILLIONS AND THIS IS
EACH YEAR EVERY YEAR THAT THEY
HAVE NOT PAID THEIR TAXES SO
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO CATCH ANYBODY OFF GUARD
UNLESS THEY'RE IN A POSITION
MENTALLY THAT THEY ARE NOT AWARE
OF THEIR OWN FINANCES IN WHICH
CASE WHEN YOU GO TO PUT ON THE
TAX BILL AND WE DISCOVER THAT.
NORMALLY THEY'RE REFERRED TO
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND WE
WOULD NEVER TAKE THAT PROPERTY
TAX ALL RIGHT THEN WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING WE COULD TO FIRST
HELP THE OWNER BECOME CURRENT
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S REALLY STRUGGLING ON THE
COMMITTEES REALLY STRUGGLING MY
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE IS WITH ON
THE MEASURE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
HELP THE OWNER GET CURRENT AND
RESTORE THE PROPERTY TO TAX
PAYING PROPERTY I WANT TO GO TO
CHAPTER EIGHT IT BECOMES A
NONPROFIT OWNED. I PIECE OF
PROPERTY THAT COMES OFF THE TAX
WILL FOREVER WHICH IN CERTAIN
CASES LIKE HOUSING OF COURSE YOU
KNOW THAT WE NEED MORE BUT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE COUNTY
TAX COLLECTORS TO GET OVER THOSE
TWO HURDLES I'M JUST FOR CONTEXT
AND SAN FRANCISCO THEY WAIT NINE
YEARS BECAUSE TEN YEARS IS WHEN
YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE IT THEY WORK
FOR WITH POPULAR FOR NINE YEARS
TO TRY TO GET THEM CURRENT
BEFORE THEY DO IT- AND PLASTER
COUNTY. BECAUSE OF THE SNOW LOAD
IN THE TIMING THEY DON'T DO IT
UNTIL ABOUT SIX AND A HALF YEARS
AND BECAUSE YOU CAN'T EVEN TAKE
PEOPLE TO SEE THE PROPERTY A
SOME TIME. BECAUSE OF THE- IN ST
BERNARD DINO WITH. THEY DON'T
CONSIDER IT UNTIL SIX OR SEVEN
YEARS. SO THEY'RE TRYING REALLY
HARD WITH THE RESIDENTIAL.
PROPERTY NOT TO TAKE IT TO ANY
KIND OF SALE LET ALONE CHAPTER
EIGHT. THAT'S WHY WE'RE STILL IN
OPPOSITION BUT AGAIN I WANT TO
COMMEND. THE AUTHORS OFFICES
BEEN NOTHING BUT ENGAGING WITH
US AND TRYING TO WORK. AND WORK
SOMETHING OUT BUT IT'S JUST A
FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT OVER.
THE USE OF CHAPTER EIGHT AND
EXPANDING. THE USE OF IT TO.
SEPARATE PEOPLE FROM THEIR
PROPERTY AND TURN IT OVER TO A-
A NON TAXING. NON TEXT
GENERATING. AT THIS PROPERTY SO.
THAT'S OPPOSITION I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. AND
SENATE. EDUCATIONAL PROCESS FOR
ME AS WELL WITH THESE TWO
CHAPTERS THAT. THANK YOU- I I'M
SURE THERE WILL BE AN ART I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANY OTHER.
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. DO
OF. DR CORRECT YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. FOR THE OPPOSITION
WITNESS- CIVIL I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN- SO IF FOR SOME REASON
THE PROPERTY GOES UP ON CHAPTER
SEVEN. AND NOBODY BIDS ON IT.
FAN COULD GO TO CHAPTER EIGHT.
IT COULD THAT'S NOT IT'S NOT A
LAW THAT REQUIRES AND WE'RE NO
REQUIRED TO DO CHAPTER EIGHT.
THEY CAN TAKE IT TO OPERATE IF
THERE'S A INTERESTED PARTY THAT
WANTS TO COME FORWARD THAT'S
PART OF OUR PROBLEM HER BILL IS
TRYING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
NOT. MAYBE NONPROFITS NOT
KNOWING HOW TO NAVIGATE THE
CHAPTER EIGHT PROCESS BECAUSE
IT'S SORT OF VOLUNTARY- NORMALLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN CHAPTER
SEVEN IS IF IT DOESN'T GET THE
MINIMUM BID THEY CAN READ THE
CAN DO RE OFFER SALE ABOUT A
MONTH LATER OR JUST STAYS ON THE
ROLE AND THEY KEEP TRYING TO
WORK WITH THE HOMEOWNER. I'M
PARTICULARLY AFTER TWO YEARS THE
PANDEMIC THERE'S A LOT OF EXTRA
EFFORT BEING PUT INTO THAT- SO
IT'S IT AUTOMATICALLY WOULD
CONTINUE TO BE ELIGIBLE IN
CHAPTER SEVEN THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT WE GO TO TOP.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT THAT HELPS
THANK YOU- JUST ASSERTED.
AUTHOR- THERE WAS A RECENT CASE
YOU PROBABLY HEARD OF WHERE THE
STREET WAS OWNED BY HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND CHAIRMAN CISCO.
AND IT WENT UP. IT ACTUALLY WENT
UP FOR A- CHAPTER SEVEN SAID OR
I HAVE A SEVEN OR EIGHT BUT IT
WENT UP FOR SALE SOMEBODY BOUGHT
IT SIGHT UNSEEN. AND IT TURNED
OUT IT WAS THE STREET. WHICH NOW
YOUNG STREET IN THE MIDDLE OF
PRIVATE DEVELOPMENT- THINGS
HAPPENED AND I'M VERY CONCERNED
THAT SOMETHING COULD HAPPEN AND
SOMEONE COULD LOSE THEIR EQUITY
BECAUSE THEY JUST YOU ARE UNABLE
TO FIND THEM SO I HAVE THAT
CONCERN ABOUT YOUR BILL THANK
YOU. OUR RIGHTS TO AT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- I AM
HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU
MISTER CORK AND SEE IF WE CAN-
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS IN SOME
OTHER WAY- YOU KNOW I THINK
WHAT'S PRIMARILY DRIVING THIS
BILL IS JUST THE NEED FOR MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND TO ME
THAT OUT WAYS SOME OF THE ISSUES
AND I THINK. YOU KNOW WHEN WE
HAVE THIS EPIDEMIC OF
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS OUR STATE
TRYING TO PUT ALL SOLUTIONS ON
THE TABLES THE GOAL BUT I HEAR
YOU ON THAT CONCERN AND I'M
HAPPY TO. CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU AND MEET ITH YOU WANTED IF
THERE'S A WAY WE CAN KIND OF IT
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
I'M HAPPY DID CONTINUE ALSO TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION IF WE
CAN FIND OTHER WAYS TO WORK
TOGETHER- BURKE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. RIGHT OF. LET'S TAKE A
VOTE- DID WE HAVE MOTION.
CORRECT WHERE THE MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF PETRIE-NORRIS
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BEEN
SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE BILL TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI-
WHEN I WHEN. LINNELL GRAY
GRAYSON GRAYSON I LIVING. LEVINE
NOT VOTING MAYES. MAYES NOT
VOTING CALDERON PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I'D QUIRK. KIRK
NOT LOADING SANTIAGO SEYARTO.
THREE THE BILL SOME QUOTES THREE
BOOKS RIGHTS OF BILLS ON CALL
AND YOU THE RESULTS THANK YOU
THAT IS WHEN WILL YOU TAKE OVER
FOR. ME PLEASE. THE NEXT BILL ON
OUR AGENDAS A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE- MADAM CHAIR WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THE BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU OF- IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN OUR STATE ESTABLISH THE-
CAL E. I. T. C. A WITH THE
BIPARTISAN GOAL OF PUTTING MONEY
BACK INTO THE POCKETS OF WORKING
CALIFORNIANS DESPITE THIS
LEGISLATION MANY ELIGIBLE
TAXPAYERS ARE STILL NOT CLAIMING
THE EITC CREDIT AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY THREE. IS A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WILL BUILD ON PRIOR
LEGISLATION TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR TAXPAYERS TO APPLY FOR AND
CLAIM THE CREDIT FURTHER
REDUCING ANY FILING BURDENS
PLACED ON TAXPAYERS AS
LEGISLATORS WE ALL HAVE A COMMON
GOAL OF MAKING SURE THAT WORKING
CALIFORNIANS ARE CLAIMING THE
STATE'S EITC CREDIT AND THE NEXT
LOGICAL STEP IS ACHIEVING THAT
GOAL GIVEN THAT AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY THREE IS STILL A WORK IN
PROGRESS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS WHO
HAVE REACHED OUT TO DISCUSS THE
BILL. I WOULD LIKE FOR I WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH-
FTP TAX PROFESSIONALS AND
SOFTWARE COMPANIES TO IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIANS EITC.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY.
PRIMARY WITNESSES WISHES TO
SPEAK. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS JENNIFER TANAH HELL WITH
ERIN RIVAS AND ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF ENROLLED AGENTS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT'LL
EASE THAT. THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BILL. AND SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU ANY AS ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MEMBERS. I'M SURE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE OF THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I
THE- THANK YOU- THIS IS WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND- THE
MOTIONS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATION. IS HIGHLAND.
ON AB TWO OH FIVE FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. IF
WE'RE ON BOTH. PRICES OF THE I
THINK I'M AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI IRWIN I
NGUYEN VOTING WHEN NOT VOTING.
GRAY GRAYSON GRAYSON I LEVINE
LEVINE AYE MAYES. MAYES NOT
VOTING. CALDERON PETRIE-NORRIS
IT YOURS LIKE WORK FOR QUICK
SANTIAGO SAY ARE TO OF. FOR
CALLING. ALL RIGHT AND I WAS ON
CALL WE ARE WAITING FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL VOTE- JUST- AGAIN AS
TO REPEAT THAT WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ITEMS NINE AND TEN UP FOR
US DOES THAT NEED TO GET ALL THE
VOTES OUT OF THE WAY SO- THE
FIRST BILL IS AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR. PEOPLE ALL RIGHT THERE IS
A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK AND A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON ALLEN THE MOTION. WHAT IS MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MADAM SECRETARY
ON EIGHTY TWO OH FIVE FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI- WHEN I
WHEN I GRAY GRAYSON. GRAYSON HI
LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES MAYES I
CALDERON PETRIE-NORRIS EACH
UNIVERSITY I. BURKE I SANTIAGO
SEYARTO. ALL RIGHT LET'S PASSED
THAT BILL HAS PASSED AND NOW WE
ARE ON FILE ITEM TEN AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY NINE SANTIAGO OF THE
RECOMMENDATION IS AN AYE VOTE ON
THAT IS THERE A MOTION MOVED.
ALL OF MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE AND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MISS
HIGHLAND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE
THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI- WHEN I
WHEN I GREAT. GRAYSON GRAYSON I
LEAN. LEVINE I MAYES. NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I'D QUIRK HI
CORRECT I SANTIAGO SANTA. BILLS
HEY AND THAT BILL IS OUT NOW WE
ARE ON I DON'T SEE MISTER
BIGELOW HERE- YOU ARE OKAY- ARE
YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO RIGHT OKAY
PLEASE. MISTRANSLATED IS GOING
TO BE PRESENTING ON FILE ITEM
THE FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY THREE SORRY MR FONG
IT LOOKED LIKE YOU WERE ALMOST
UP. BUT ALAS. BLESSED MADAM VICE
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M HERE PRESENTING
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TWO ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLYMAN
FRANK BIGELOW WHO IS UNABLE TO
BE HERE AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
TWO WOULD MAKE INDIVIDUALS OR
SMALL BUSINESSES ELIGIBLE FOR
TAX CREDITS WHEN THEY PURCHASE A
GENERATOR FOR BACKUP ENERGY
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL TARGETS
THOSE IN CAL FIRE'S HIGH OR VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONE OR AN AREA
THAT EXPERIENCES ONE OR MORE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER STRUTS
OFFICE. SHUT OFFS IN THE LAST
TAXABLE YEAR THIS TAX CREDIT
AIMS TO COVER HIGH CAUGHT THEM
COVER HALF OF THE COST OF THE
GENERATOR UP TO NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AS DO MOST OF OUR
DISTRICTS THAT MR BIGELOW'S
CONSTITUENTS SUFFER FROM POWER
OUTAGES DUE TO WEATHER OR
WILDFIRES DURING EACH FIRE
SEASON. PROVIDING SOME RELIEF TO
PEOPLE WHO PURCHASED GENERATES
FOR RELIABLE BACKUP ENERGY WHEN
THOSE SITUATIONS DO OCCUR IS A
WAY TO HELP OUR- COMMUNITIES FOR
EXAMPLE FROM TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN TO. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE THERE WERE SIXTY SEVEN POWER
SHUT OFFS WHICH IMPACTED ROUGHLY
TWO POINT SIX MILLION CUSTOMERS.
UNFORTUNATE DURING THESE
OUTRAGES PEOPLE LOSE FOOD OR ARE
FORCED TO SPEND MONEY A HOTEL IN
AN AREA WITH POWER. THIS CAN BE
INCREDIBLY DISRUPTIVE PARTICULAR
SHUT OFF FOR SEVERAL DAYS LONG
AB TWENTY NINETY TWO ENCOURAGES
PEOPLE TO INVEST IN A BACK UP
GENERATOR TO HELP ENSURE THEY
HAVE. RELIABLE ENERGY IN THE
EVENT THE GREATEST AUTO
OPERATING. AND WHETHER IT'S
APPROPRIATE TIME- MR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THOUGH WOULD BE ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHTS AND
YOU ARE A PRIMARY WITNESS I
ASSUME CORRECT GOOD AFTERNOON
JOHN KENNEDY WITH A RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THIRTY NINE WORLD
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TWO.
OUR COUNTIES TO BORN THE BRUNT
OF THE P. S. P. S. OUTAGES OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND THOSE
HAVE BEEN SUPPLANTED BY E. P. S.
S. OUTAGES. OF MUCH SHORTER
DURATION BUT MUCH GREATER
FREQUENCY- THOSE ROLLED OUT IN
JUST A FEW COUNTIES LAST YEAR
BUT THEY'RE EXPECTED TO GO OUT
AND MANY MORE COUNTIES THIS
YEAR. AND ALL THESE OUTAGES
WHETHER MULTI DAY OUTAGES FOR
TWELVE HOUR OUTAGES REALLY
BECAUSE A LOT OF ECONOMIC
DISLOCATION AND SAFETY ISSUES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. FOR SOME OF THE
RESIDENTS IT CAN BE A MATTER OF
BEING ABLE TO USE YOUR WATER
PUMP TO PUMP WATER TO THE GROUND
FOR SANITATION DRINKING AND
FIREFIGHTING. SO WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO SUPPORT TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY TWO WE THINK IT WILL HELP
BRING BACK SOME OF THE ENERGY
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCE THAT
A LOT OF OUR CALIFORNIANS.
THOUGHT THEY HAD UNTIL THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WOULD RATHER NOT
HAVE OUTRAGEOUS WE'D RATHER HAVE
THE VERY SAFE ENERGY GRID- AND
WE THINK THIS WILL HELP US BUILD
IN SOME OF THE RELIABILITY THAT
WE ONCE HAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND ARE THERE ANY OTHER-
PRIMARY- I MEAN ANY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. DO WE HAVE
ANY. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I'LL I'LL ASK WHEN I
TO YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS- WHAT
PERCENT OF THESE GENERATORS ARE-
DIESEL GENERATORS BECAUSE MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE ARE REALLY
YOU KNOW WE'RE BUT WE HAVE. BIG
GOALS TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES
AND WOULDN'T THIS JUST BE-
MOVING IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
OF THAT POLICY SO IT DEPENDS ON
THE APPLICATION A LOT OF THESE
GENERATORS ESPECIALLY FOR SOME
BUSINESSES WILL BE DIESEL
GENERATORS JUST BECAUSE THEY CAN
DRIVE THE OUTPUT THAT'S
NECESSARY OR THESE THINGS- AT
THE SAME TIME WE DON'T EXPECT
THESE TO BE USED FREQUENTLY OR
USED OFTEN AND SO IT'S A MATTER
OF. PROVIDING THE BASIC
NECESSITIES OF LIFE WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE MORE MICRO GRIDS-
DEPLOYED WITH CLEAN ENERGY- BUT
UNLESS AND UNTIL THAT HAPPENS
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE POWER- AND
IT'S REALLY TOUGH TO MAINTAIN A
VIBRANT COMMUNITY AND A WORKING
pRELIABLE POWER. RIGHT THANK YOU
A- I WAS WAITING FOR YOU DOCTOR
FOR- I STILL WAS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE FIRST TWO BILLS-
SO ON THIS ONE- I DO FOR YEAH
I'D- TO TRY AND SAY DO SOLAR AND
BATTERY SHE'S GOING TO BE FOUR
OR FIVE TIMES MORE EXPENSIVE SO
I THINK. DIESEL IS THE ONLY-
MICHAEL LIKELY- ALTERNATIVE FOR
SOMEONE DOING BACKUP POWER
UNLESS THEY'RE JUST GETTING
SOLAR FOR DAY TO DAY USE. OUR
BUT IT'S STILL PRETTY EXPENSIVE
SO I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY YOU GO
TO DIESEL AND IT PROBABLY WON'T
BE USED ALL THAT OFF BECAUSE
FRANKLY THE GRADES CHEAPER THAN.
RUNNING OFF DIESEL FUEL HOWEVER.
WHAT I AM CONCERNED ABOUT WITH
ANY TAX CREDIT IS THAT IT GOES
TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
AND PERHAPS DR MISTER BIGELOW
COULD TALK TO ME ABOUT IT- IT'S
GOING TO GO TO EVERYBODY WHETHER
THEY NEED IT OR NOT WHETHER THEY
WOULD HAVE DONE THIS OR NOT.
USUALLY YOU HAVE A- TAX
INCENTIVE TO GET SOME PEOPLE TO
DO SOMETHING THEY WOULDN'T. SO
THAT'S A CONCERN- THE OTHER
THING IS THIS IS GOING TO
INVOLVE A LOT OF MONEY. WOULD WE
BE BETTER OFF JUST HAVING A
GRANT PROGRAM. TO HELP PEOPLE
BUY THESE FOR PEOPLE WHO
OTHERWISE COULDN'T AFFORD IT.
THOSE ARE JUST QUESTIONS RIGHT
NOW BUT MISTER BIGELOW COULD
TALK TO ME ABOUT IT LATER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES SAID. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND TO ADDRESS THE DIESEL
ISSUE THE GOOD NEWS IS. IS THAT
IT'S NOT YOUR TRADITIONAL DIESEL
LEFT. FROM FOSSIL FUELS- THE WE
ARE NOW WORKING ON TECHNOLOGY OF
DIESEL FROM RENEWABLES. AND IT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT HERE IN OR RIGHT
IN MY DISTRICT SO IT'S COMING
FROM. GOOD SOURCES AND IT'S
CONSIDERED RENEWABLE DIESEL. WE
ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WHEN IT COMES TO
DIESEL THANK YOU FOR THAT- THAT
. BIT OF INFORMATION THERE ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU OF WOULD
YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING STATEMENTS
THEY'LL JUST ON BEHALF OF A
SOMEONE BIGELOW WHEN THIS
OPPORTUNITY COMES UP HE WOULD
LIKE TO ASK WHEN I BUILT. OUR
RIGHTS- I APPRECIATE THE OF BOB
I ALL THE REST OF THE BILLS ARE
PRESENTATION ONLY AND- HOPEFULLY
WE WILL BE VOTING ON THAT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG YOU ARE UP. AND PRESENTING. TWENTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THIS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
PROVIDES ACTUALLY TO
CALIFORNIA'S HEROES THAT HAVE
SERVED A MILITARY THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IN OUR
STATE ISRAEL THE AVERAGE PRICE
OF A HOME IN CALIFORNIA IS OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
AN AMOUNT THAT'S AND THAT'S
UNATTAINABLE FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING VETERANS
TO EASE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
THIS BILL DOUBLES THE URRENT
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTIONS FOR
DISABLED VETERANS. IT INCREASES
THE EXEMPTION AMOUNT TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
DISABLED VETERANS AND THREE
DISABLED VETERANS WHOSE
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES ARE UNDER
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS CURRENT
LAW EXAMS ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTIONS FOR DISABLED VETERANS
AND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR DISABLED VETERANS
WHOSE HOUSEHOLD INCOMES ARE
UNDER FORTY THOUSAND. VETERANS
WHO WERE INJURED IN THEIR
SERVICE OUR COUNTRY SHOULD BE
AFFORDED EVERY COMBINATION
POSSIBLE PLAN RETURNING HOME A
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO SERVE
OUR COUNTRY INVESTOR LIVES
DEFEND THE FREEDOMS WE ENJOY
EACH AND EVERY DAY FOR THAT
REASON WE SHOULD GIVE THEM SOME
TAX RELIEF- HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT HISCOCK OFTEN WITH THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AS WE WHEN I- I
VOTE. I TO PROTECT. A. B. TWO
EIGHT NINE EIGHT IS SIMPLE FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR FISCAL YEAR AND FOR
EACH FISCAL YEAR THERE AFTER IT
WOULD INCREASE THE PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION FOR DISABLED VETERANS.
FROM A 1-001-000-2200 THOUSAND
AND A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TO
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PER
DISABLED VETERANS WHOSE
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES ARE UNDER
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THE DISABLED VETERANS PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION HAS NOT KEPT UP
WITH SKYROCKETING HOUSING PRICES
IN CALIFORNIA. BY INCREASING
THIS ABLED VETERANS PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION WE CAN HELP BETTER
PROTECT THOSE WHO HAVE
SELFLESSLY PROTECTED US. WE OWE
THEM THIS AND SO MUCH MORE WHEN
THE TIME COMES I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PARK- SHOWED
NEARLY I DON'T VOTE FOR TAX
BREAKS BUT I COULD MAKE COULD
MAKE AN EXCEPTION HERE- YOU
MIGHT IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE. STAFF
YOU MIGHT THINK OF PUTTING IN A-
HOUSING COST OF LIVING ESCALATOR
IN IT SO THAT THIS BILL DOESN'T
HAVE TO COME UP AGAIN- CERTAINLY
OPEN TO THAT AT THAT THERE IS AN
AT A COST OF THE ADJUSTMENT OF
IT ALREADY BUT IT SAYS IT HASN'T
HASN'T CAUGHT UP WITH THAT WITH
THE AFFORDABILITY CRISIS OUR
STATE YEAH THAT'S WHAT WE WANT
TO INCREASE THE BASE EXEMPTION
BECAUSE IT'S GONE UP MUCH MORE
THAN THE COST OF LIVING AND I'M
SAYING MAYBE PUT A BABY THE
ESCALATOR SHOULD BE TIED TO THE
COST OF LEVEL ABSOLUTELY. I
GUESS COST OF HAPPENING RIGHT
AND THE COST OF LIVING
ABSOLUTELY- THAT'S A THOUGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF NEARLY
WOULD OFFER THAT WE WERE OFF
WILLING TO TAKE A MINUTES INTO
THEIR THE BAYLOR TODAY TO CHANGE
THAT EXPAND THE BILL PROVIDE
MORE FLEXIBILITY YEAH THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE RARE
EXCEPTIONS WHERE I WILL VOTE FOR
TAX BREAKS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS-
ALRIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORD TO-
FILE ITEM SIX AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. AFTERNOON MISTER
WORD AFTER NEW MADAM CHAIR. TOLD
ME I WANT TO GET SITUATED AND
I'M SURE WE HAVE THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO JOIN US- MANAGER MEMBERS
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE HOME
PRICES CLIMB STATEWIDE BY MORE
THAN 17% AND IN SOME REGIONS OF
OUR STATE EXCEEDED MORE THAN.
20% IN A SINGLE CALENDAR YEAR
WITH FORECASTS OF COURSE ON THE
RISE FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO NOW
THIS IS GENERALLY ATTRIBUTED TO
OUR CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE IN
PRODUCTION AND THE SUPPLY DEMAND
BALANCES BUILT UP OVER THE
DECADES. WHAT THE- NEW HOME
PERMITS HAVE ALL RISEN AFTER
YEARS OF DECLINE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND AS YOU ALL KNOW
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK ON MANY
OF THE SUPPLY SIDE QUESTIONS.
SPECULATED SPECULATIVE ACTIVITY
HOWEVER IS ANOTHER SILENT
DRIVING FORCE OF THE RECENT
RECORD HOME PRICES WE'VE SEEN
THIS GROWING TREND OF SHORT TERM
INVESTORS AFFECTING HOUSING
COSTS IN RESALE PROPERTIES.
VACANT RESIDENTIAL LAND IN NEW
CONSTRUCTIONS. INFERRED MARKET
ANALYSIS SUGGESTS THAT INVESTOR
BOUGHT HOMES REPRESENTED
APPROXIMATELY 51% OF THE GROWTH
OF SALES YEAR OVER YEAR FROM
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY ONE. IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND AS A
PERCENT OF TOTAL SALES THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF SALES GOING
TO ALL CASH INVESTOR LIKE-
ACTIVITY IS APPROACHING A RECORD
18% AND RISING. WHEN EQUITIES
SPECULATORS ENTERED THE MARKET
THE OFTEN OUTBID WOULD BE A LONG
TIME HOMEOWNERS WITH A CASH ONLY
OFFER OF THEIR OWN. SEEKING TO
MAXIMIZE GAINS AND REDUCE RISK
THE SELLING SHORT TIME LATER
WHEN THEY CAN ACHIEVE AN EVEN
HIGHER PRICE AND THIS RAISES
COMPARABLE SALES FIGURES FOR NEW
PRODUCTS TO BE PUT ON THE
MARKET. PUSHING HOME PRICES EVEN
HIGHER WHEN HIGHER COST
PROPERTIES A RAISED MIDDLE
INCOME PROPERTIES BECOME HIGHER
COSTS AND LOWER INCOME
PROPERTIES ARE RE TO THE- WELL
IN. BUYER AND LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS OUT MY UP. THERE ARE
FEES ARE THE BASIC NEGATIVE
EXTERNALITIES FROM THIS
ACTIVITY. EVERYONE'S COST
BURDENS ARE RAISED AND MORE
PEOPLE ARE PUSHED TOWARDS THE
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS OR SAYING
GOODBYE TO CALIFORNIA. UNCHECKED
THIS MARKET FAILURE IS
FRUSTRATING OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
GET INTO THEIR HOME AND RISKING
OUR POTENTIAL FOR AT LEAST A
GENERATION. AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
ONE BEFORE YOU WOULD IMPOSE A
25% SUR TAX ON THE PROFIT FROM A
QUICK SALE OF A HOME OR
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY. BY
INVESTORS SEEKING SHORT TERM
INVESTMENTS AFTER THE THIRTY
YEAR- IT HAS INTRODUCED OF THE
ORIGINAL PURCHASE THE SURTAX TO
BE REDUCED BY TWENTY PERCENT.
UNTIL IT'S FULLY REDUCED BY YEAR
SEVEN. GENERATED FUNDS ARE NOT
HERE FOR THE STATE THEY WOULD BE
INSTEAD ALLOCATED TO CAP TO
CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SUPPORT SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND TO
CITIES AND UNINCORPORATED AREAS
FOR COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE ALL
DESPERATELY NEEDED. THEY ARE
TIED TO PROPERTY. THE TAX SELL
EXEMPTS. OWNER OCCUPIED HOMES
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS ACTIVE
MILITARY PERSONNEL SITES
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SITES WERE THE SAME. THERE IS
LIST THE TOTAL PROPERTY YOU'RE
PART VITAL PROPERTY UNAVAILABLE
OPEN SPACE OR VACATED SPACE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSCORE
THIS IS NOT A GENERAL TAX
PROPOSAL AND IT ISN'T ABOUT
BRINGING MONEY INTO THE STATE.
IF IT HAD ITS INTENDED EFFECT
ACTIVITY WOULD BE REDUCED NO TAX
TO BE COLLECTED THE MARKET WOULD
STABILIZE AND WORKING FAMILIES
WOULD WIN. THIS IS ABOUT USING
OUR TAX POLICY TO CHANGE
BEHAVIOR AND HELP MORE WOULD BE
HOME OWNERS ACTUALLY GET THEIR
BID IS ACCEPTED. HOWEVER ANY
REVENUES THAT WERE COLLECTED
WILL BE SENT RIGHT BACK INTO
COMMUNITIES ALSO A WIN. AND THIS
ISN'T THE FIRST TIME THAT
SPECULATION HAS BEEN PRESENT IN
THE BALTIMORE MARC MARKET CYCLES
AND IT WILL BE THE LAST. BUT IT
IS TIMELY THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER A FINANCIAL CONTROL TO
DISCOURAGE SPECULATION TO GIVE
WORKING CALIFORNIANS THE EDGE
TO. BUY INTO THEIR OWN COMMUNITY
AND ONLY AT A BETTER PRICE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A RESPONSE. TO
FIRST. WHAT ARE HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR. HOMES ARE PLACES
FOR FAMILIES AND PEOPLE TO LIVE
IN. HOMES HELP PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES PRESERVE AND GROW THEIR
WEALTH. AT THE EXPENSE OF PEOPLE
AND FAMILIES. HOMES ARE NOT A
QUICK TRADE ON THE MARKET.
ACTIVITY THAT'S CREATING A
MARKET FAILURE. BENEFITING THOSE
WITH INCREDIBLE MEANS AND
LEAVING EVERYONE ELSE BEHIND. I
LOOK FOR YOUR QUESTIONS IN THE
DISCUSSION TODAY. THIS WILL BE A
GAME CHANGING POLICY PROPOSAL
THAT'S USED ELSEWHERE IN THE
WORLD BUT THE FIRST TIME. IT
WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES IT'S ACTUALLY
REFLECTING RESPONSES THAT WERE
SEEN. WORLDWIDE NOT LIKE TO
PRESENT MY WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL RATE LONG REPRESENTING
HOUSING NOW. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
REVEREND RAJAN FONG AND I AM A
SENIOR ORGANIZER WITH HOUSING
NOW AND ALSO PRESBYTERIAN PASTOR
HEARING LOSS JUST WILL NOT HERE
BUT DOWN BELOW. HOUSING NOW IS A
BROAD AND DIVERSE MOVEMENT
BUILDING COALITION WITH OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE HOUSING
AFFORDABLE. AND TO COMBAT
DISPLACEMENT CRISIS THAT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY SEVENTY ONE. AS YOU ALL
ARE WHERE WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
A HOUSING CRISIS LIMITED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
THE AVERAGE WORKING CALIFORNIANS
DEPLETING IT DEPLETED BY RISING
RENTS AND MEDIUM HOME PRICES.
ARE SEVEN TIMES THAT MOST
HOUSEHOLDS MAKE. IN ORDER TO
AFFORD AVERAGE RENTS IN THE
STATE WORKERS NEED TO EARN MORE
THAN THIRTY EIGHT DOLLARS PER
HOUR. INCREASINGLY RENTERS ARE
BEING PUSHED OUT BY A FAIRLY
UNREGULATED RENTAL MARKET RUN BY
AN EXPANSIVE EVER AGREEMENT
ALKALIZING CORPORATE REALIST
INDUSTRY. TODAY THE AVERAGE
WORKING BRING IN SEEKING
HOMEOWNERSHIP. OUT OVER THIRTY
TIMES AFTER LOSING TO ALL BASH
SHORT TERM REAL ESTATE INVESTORS
. EVERY TWENTY ONE PRECIOUS
HELLO ANTS FOR JUST THE- ONE OF
A- SO FIVE OF INVESTOR HOME
PURCHASES WERE PAID FOR WITH ALL
CASH. 35% OF THESE INVESTOR HOME
PURCHASES WERE SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES. IN A REDFIN REPORT AND
INVESTOR TO THE ACROSS THE
NATION IT WAS FOUND THAT
INVESTORS BOUGHT AN AVERAGE OF
15% OF HOMES DEMONSTRATING A
TREND. A SPECULATIVE ACTIVITY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. IN
PARTICULAR THE STUDY SHOWED A
DISPROPORTIONATE TARGETING OF
MAJORITY BLACK AND BROWN
NEIGHBORHOODS BY INVESTORS WITH
30% OF HOME SALES IN MAJORITY
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS COMPARED
WITH ONLY 12% AND OTHERS. THESE
TRENDS LOOK THE SAME HERE IN OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN MY OWN
CITY OF LOS ANGELES OVER ALL AN
AVERAGE OF 10% OF HOMES WERE
BOUGHT BY INVESTORS THE LOS
ANGELES. MEANWHILE 27% OF HOMES
IN HISTORICALLY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS LA WERE BOUGHT BY
INVESTORS LAST YEAR WELL OVER
DOUBLE THE CITY AVERAGE. IN ONE
BLACK AND BROWN MAJORITY
NEIGHBORHOOD AROUND USC
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHRN
CALIFORNIA. 48% ALMOST HALF OF
THE HOMES PURCHASED LAST YEAR
WERE BY SPECULATORS AND THAT ONE
NEIGHBORHOOD. THIS STORY OF
DISPLACEMENT EVER WORKING POOR
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TODAY
NOT ONLY CONTINUES OUR NATION'S
RICH SPUR SSTEMIC RACIST
PRACTICES OF RED LINING. BUT IS
CONTRIBUTING TO THE
RESEGREGATION OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AS DEMONSTRATED BY REPORT
RECENTLY BY THE URBAN HABITAT.
POOR WORKING CLASS FAMILIES OF
COLOR ARE BEING PUSHED INTO THE
OUTSKIRTS EVER COMMUNITIES WITH
FEWER RESOURCES. LOSS OF
GENERATIONAL SUPPORT LONG
COMMUTES TO WORK INCREASING BUT
TRAFFIC AND POLLUTION. AND LESS
TIME TO INVEST IN OUR FAMILIES
OUR SCHOOLS OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND EVEN BEYOND MY WORK AS A
HOUSING ORGANIZER DALY I HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AS A PASTOR AND
JUST AS A RESIDENTS WITH MY
NEIGHBORS AND FRIENDS FOR
EXASPERATED BY THE HOUSING
MARKET. AND HAVE RECEIVED
EVICTION NOTICES ALREADY
CONSIDERING MOVING INTO A VAN OR
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE AWAY FROM
FAMILY AD FRIENDS THIS IS THE
REALITY THAT OUR CITIES AND OUR
STATE IS FACING RIGHT NOW
PERHAPS MANY OF YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE SAME IN YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. I MYSELF AS A
SINGLE WORKING PARENTS HAVE LOOK
FOR YEARS TO EXPAND OUTSIDE MY
TINY SEVEN HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT
APARTMENT WITH A GROWING TO
CHILDREN BUT I'VE GIVEN NOT
BECAUSE OF THE RISING COSTS. IN
MY OWN COMMUNITY LIKE MANY
SINGLE PARENTS I CANNOT AFFORD
TO LOSE A COMMUNITY I HAVE
SUPPORT. I COMMITTEE SUPPORT I
HAVE SURROUNDING MY CHILDREN NOR
DO I HAVE THE MEANS TO MOVE TO A
HEALTHIER MORE SUSTAINABLE
SITUATION IN MY OWN NEIGHBORHOOD
. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS RACE CLASS
AND REGION SIMPLY CANNOT COMPETE
WITH A LARGE CORPORATIONS LOCAL
COMPANIES AND WEALTHY BUYERS.
SPECULATORS WHO SEE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS
SOLELY AS INVESTMENTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PROFIT RATHER
THAN HOMES THAT ARE WORKING
FAMILIES DESPERATELY NEED. AND
AS HOMEOWNERSHIP BECOMES EVER
MORE UNAFFORDABLE FOR THE
AVERAGE FAMILY LARGE
CORPORATIONS HAVE GREATER
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSOLIDATE THEIR
MARKET SHARE. ALSO WE MUST NOT
PUT A BLIND EYE TO THE FACT THAT
THIS IS NOT ONLY IS THIS
SPECULATION DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTING CAN USE OF COLOR THAT
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED. IT ALSO MOVES
US BACKWARDS IN OUR FIGHT FOR
RACIAL EQUALITY AND EQUITY WE
SIMPLY CANNOT ALLOW PROFITS TO
DETERMINE THE WEALTH AND HEALTH
OF OUR COMMUNITIES WE CAN DO
BETTER AND WE WILL DO BETTER AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS COMMUNITY
IN THIS COMMITTEE. CAN DO THAT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
ONE IS A REAL SOLUTION THAT WILL
TEMPER GLOBAL SPECULATORS
PROVIDE ACCOUNTABILITY AND BRING
REAL LASTING CHANGE FOR THE
FAMILIES THAT NEED IT MOST IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. IT WILL CREATE
A FISCAL DISINCENTIVES THAT
ENCOURAGED SPECULATORS TO FIND
SOMETHING ELSE TO INVEST IN SIR
FAMILIES WILL BE GIVEN A CHANCE
TO LITTLE HOMES BE WHAT THEY
WERE MEANT TO BE. HOMES A
HEALTHY AFFORDABLE AND STABLE
PLACE WHERE FAMILIES A PLACE FOR
MY OWN CHILDREN TO LAY THEIR
HEADS. THE MOST POWERFUL ROLE
GOVERNMENT CAN PLAY IN HELPING
EVERYDAY FAMILIES. IS NOT ONLY
THE PAST POLICIES THAT PROVIDE
RELIEF IN THE MOMENT. BOSTON
CREATE POLICIES AND SOLUTIONS
THAT WAS CLOSER TOWARDS DIGNITY
HEALTH AND WELLNESS FOR ALL.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS
LABOR UNIONS AND NEIGHBORHOOD
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE. WE
DO BELIEVE EIGHTY SOMETHING
SEVENTY ONE IS ONE OF THOSE
POLICIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SURE
MEMBERS CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH
CORBIN KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. RIGHT. OKAY DO WE HAVE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
VANESSA CHAVEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE JUST JUST
WANT TO CHECK YOUR THE PRIMARY
WITNESS RIGHT OKAY. AB SEVENTY
SEVENTY ONE WOULD IMPOSE AN
UNPRECEDENTED TAX OF UP 225% ON
PROPERTY OWNERS IF THEY SELL
THEIR PROPERTY PRIOR TO SEVEN
YEARS. BY IMPOSING AN ADDITIONAL
TAX ON THE GAIN. FROM SELLING A
HOUSE IT DIMINISHES WEALTH
BUILDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOUNGER AND MORE DIVERSE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIANS NOW
BUYING HOMES FURTHERING THE
WEALTH INEQUITY IN THE STATE. IT
ALSO LIMITS THE FREEDOM TO MOVE
OR RELOCATE. WHICH IS ESPECIALLY
TROUBLING AS OFTEN MANY PROPERTY
OWNERS ARE FACED WITH THE NEED
TO RELOCATE. DUE TO AN
UNFORESEEN LIFE OF THAT WHICH
INCLUDES BUT IS NOT LIMITED TO A
JOB LOSS OR DIVORCE OR EVEN A
DISABILITY AND FURTHER AT THIS
BILL NEGATIVELY IMPACTS HOUSING
SUPPLY. WELL AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE IS TOUTED AS A BILL
THAT WILL BRING NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HOME BUYERS.
WHO HAVE BEEN OUTBID IN THE
PURCHASE OF A HOME ACTUALLY HAS
THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE AFFECT OF
ITS INTENT. THIS BILL
PRIORITIZES CORPORATE OWNERSHIP
OVER FAMILY OWNERSHIP BY
CONTINUING TO ENABLE INVESTORS
TO PURCHASE PROPERTIES FOR THE
PURPOSE OF RUNNING THEM OUT AND
THEN REDUCES THE SUPPLY OF HOMES
FOR OWNER OCCUPANTS BY
INCENTIVIZING CORPORATE BUYERS
TO HOLD ON TO THEIR PROPERTIES
UNTIL THE SEVEN YEAR. SEASONING
PERIOD EXPIRES LEADING TO LESS
HOUSING INVENTORY AVAILABLE FOR
SALE AND EQUITY GAINS. TO GO TO
THE COMPANIES AS OF APRIL TWENTY
FIRST. BANKRATE REPORTED THAT
INTEREST RATES FOR A THIRTY YEAR
MORTGAGE HAVE REACHED FIVE POINT
TWO EIGHT PERCENT. WITH INTEREST
RATES LIKELY TO CONTINUE TO RISE
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE JUST
ADDS MORE COST HURDLES FOR HOME
BUYERS. NOT ONLY ARE HOME BUYERS
FACED WITH RISING INTEREST
RATES. BUT UNDER AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE IT WILL ALSO
CONSTRICTED HOUSING SUPPLY AS
INVESTORS HOLD ON TO THEIR
PROPERTIES. WHICH WILL FURTHER
RESULT IN COST INCREASES TO THE
PRICE OF A HOME. C. A. R. ALSO
HAS CONCERNS ABOUT CORPORATE
OWNERSHIP AND THE ABILITY OF
OWNER OCCUPANT TO COMPETE IN THE
MARKETPLACE HOWEVER. AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE MISSES THE
MARK IN TRYING TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES FOR THESE REASONS CA ARE
MUST OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IS THERE A SECOND
PRIMARY WITNESS. I DON'T KNOW IF
I'M PRIMARY. BUT I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF IN THE
BRICKFIELDS REAL ESTATE GROUP
I'M SO. OKAY C. A. YEAH BECAUSE
THAT WAS TWO MINUTES AND THEN SO
YOU HAVE. ANOTHER PRIMARY
WITNESS AND YOU CAN THE PRIMARY
WITNESS CAN SIT AND. YEAH.
SCHERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TWENTY BUT WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION- HERE
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION I'LL
KEEP IT SHORT- IN A TIME OF
RECKLESS THERE'S A SURPLUS- WITH
THE STATE WOOD WE FEEL LIKE IT'S
A WRONG TIME TO IMPOSE A NEW 25%
TAX ON A PROPERTY OWNER THAT
JUST WANTS TO SELL THEIR THEIR
HOME AND TO AS THE ANNOUNCED
POINTS OUT THERE IS A NEED FOR
INVESTORS THAT TIME SOMETIMES
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS- DON'T
HAVE THE FUNDS TO UPDATE A HOME
RIGHT- AND THAT'S WHERE
INVESTORS YOU COME IN. TO
PURCHASE A HOME AND HAVE THE
CAPITAL TO UPDATED THEN TO PUT
IT BACK ON THE MARKET- FOR
ANOTHER BUYER GROUP TO PURCHASE
AND PERHAPS LIVE IN OR USED AS A
RENTAL PROPERTY AND FOR THOSE
SHORT REASONS- WE OPPOSE THE
BILL ALL RIGHT AND THEN OF OTHER
OPPOSITION YOUR NAME AND OF WHO
YOU ARE AFFILIATED. WITH IN YOUR
POSITIONS PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM MY NAME'S TERRANCE KILL.
I'M AN ATTORNEY- I'M HERE ON MY
OWN BEHALF AS WELL AS ON BEHALF
OF THE BROOK FIELDS REAL ESTATE
GROUP. A GROUP OF PRIVATE SECTOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
PURCHASE SALE FINANCING.
OWNERSHIP RENTAL AND SO FORTH I
TOOK THE LIBERTY OF SUBMITTING A
LETTER ON YOUR POSITION LETTER
PORTAL. I'D LIKE TO READ INTO
THE RECORD PLEASE AND WE'RE WE
ARE JUST DOING YOUR NAME
POSITION IF YOU WANT TO PASS THE
LETTER AROUND YOU CAN DO THAT
THE GENTLEMAN I GAVE COPIES OF
THE LETTER TO. SO AT THIS POINT
YOU'RE DENYING ME THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK. THE CORRECT. THIS IS HOW
SAY AGAIN THIS IS THE PROCESS
CAN WE HAVE THE NEXT SPEAKER
PLEASE. ALL RIGHT WATER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE MEMBERS
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MORE TOP ON BEHLF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
PAT RAN WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I DO WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR. ON YOUR
INTENTIONS- AND WHAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS- WITH- WITH
THIS BILL. IT IS- IT IT IS AN
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO HAVE
CONVERSATION IT IS AN ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO HAVE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. I SPEAK ON WITH
MULTIPLE HATS ON AND HAVING-
HAVING WENT ON A HOUSING WORKING
GROUP TOUR THIS PAST FALL
OCTOBER NOVEMBER AND SEEING- THE
IMPACT OF THE UNAFFORDABILITY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO BUY A
HOME. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
EXASPERATING THAT EFFORT FOR
PEOPLE TO BUY HOMES IS THROUGH
SPECULATION THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
NO PROBLEM AT ALL. AND I FULLY
WINNER PERCENT SUPPORT
INVESTORS- WELL I THINK
INVESTING MAKES A GREAT- MAKES
FOR A GREAT ECONOMY AND MAKES
FOR A SOLID ECONOMY. HOWEVER
WE'RE NOT- THE INTENT HERE IS TO
NOT. GO AFTER SPECIFICALLY
INVESTORS THIS IS TO GO AFTER
THOSE WHO ARE IF I READ IT
CORRECTLY WHO ARE SPECULATING
AND THEY ARE IN IT FOR. A DOLLAR
THAT ACTUALLY DOES NOT EXIST-
THE RIVER FOR A DOLLAR IN AN
INFLATED ECONOMY- WHERE THERE'S-
WHERE HOUSING IS COMPLETELY
UNAFFORDABLE AND OVER AND- I
THINK MANY WOULD AGREE OVER
PRICED. AND SO WE THROUGH
SPECULATION IT FORCES- A BUYER
TO ACTUALLY FINANCE EQUITY
THAT'S AND THAT'S NOT THE THAT'S
NOT SUSTAINABLE AND SO WITH
THAT- I'M I'M NOT SURE OF THIS
PATHWAY IS THE PATHWAY TO TAKE
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T COMPASS. SO
MANY OTHER AREAS BUT I WOULD- I
WOULD OFFER TO JOIN YOUR EFFORT
AND TRY TO COME UP WITH A
PATHWAY THAT DOES INVOLVE- THE
INPUT FROM OPPOSITION. SO THAT
WE ARE REALLY CAPTURING THOSE
WHO ARE DOING THEIR GREGIS- WORK
OF SPECULATION AND NOT GO AFTER
THOSE WHO ARE. EXERCISING THEIR
RIGHT TO BE AN INVESTOR SO- AND
I SEE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO- IS A MINUTE AS MIGHT BE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AND I TO ALL BEGIN BY
COMMENDING THAT THE AUTHOR I
THINK IN TERMS OF. YOUR INTENT
WITH THIS BILL AND BY THE GOAL
THAT YOU HAVE WITH THIS POLICY-
BUT I DO HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AS A RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND I THINK- IN. THE
FOR THE FUNDAMENTAL REASON THAT
HOUSING PRICES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE THROUGH THE ROOF
IS THAT WE HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
IMBALANCE BETWEEN DEMAND AND
SUPPLY RIGHT. DEMANDS TO HIS
SUPPLIES TOO LOW SO ANY POLICY
THAT I FURTHER CONSTRICT SUPPLY
IS ACTUALLY GOING TO EXACERBATE
THE AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THAT WE
FACE RIGHT NOW. I'M AND I THINK
THAT FIVE BY CONSTRAINING MARKET
FLUIDITY THAT THAT IS. WHAT THE
BILL WOULD BE SO I'M- SURE
YOU'VE THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
CONCERN AND WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN IN YOUR- PERSPECTIVE ON THAT
. RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY. I
WAS JUST PASSING FROM IN CASE
RESTORED WATER TO GIVE HIS
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT BUT TO. I
WILL OFFER MY COMMENTS WHICH ARE
GOING TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES'
FRANKLY- I AGREE WITH MR GRACE
COVERS THE SAYS THAT YOU WANT IT
REALLY BOTHERS ME ABOUT THIS
BILL IS A SENSE THAT INVESTING
IN A RENTAL HOME MORE TO IS
OFTEN THE WA A FAMILY- BUILDS A
NEST EGG AND BUILD WEALTH AND
BUILD AN OPPORTUNITY AND THIS
IS- COUNTERPRODUCTIVE THIS
LEGISLATION YOU HAVE BEFORE ME.
NOW IF YOU WERE TO. I DON'T KNOW
IF THERE WERE SOME EXEMPTIONS IN
HERE A DIFFERENT THRESHOLD OR
PERHAPS TARGETING A DIFFERENT.
AUDIENCE THAN MAYBE. WE CAN GET
SOMEWHERE WITH THAT BUT THE
QUESTION I THINK I'M MORE
CURIOUS ABOUT IN MY TENTH. AND
FINAL YEAR HERE AT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE- I'VE SEEN BILLS-
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE PERIOD OF
TIME. ON HOUSING. LARGELY FOR
MEMBERS WHO REPRESENT URBAN
COMMUNITIES LIKE YOURSELF- AND I
DON'T. DISAGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON SURE YOUR
INTENTIONS ARE GOOD AND TRYING
TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING NEEDS OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS- BUT IT JUST
SHOCKS ME THAT WE CONTINUE TO
BE. ABOUT TWO MILLION THREE
MILLION HOMES UNDERSUPPLY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND NOBODY BRINGS
BILLS FORWARD. TO MAKE IT EASIER
TO BUILD CHEAPER TO BUILD MORE
WORK FORCE. AND THIS IS KIND OF-
I GUESS I'D LIKE TO HEAR YOU I'D
LIKE TO HEAR YOUR PERSPECTIVE-
AS SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS A
MUCH LARGER COMMUTE IN THE
SMALL. RURAL COMMUNITIES I
REPRESENT BUT- THAT THAT THERE
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S SO MANY
HURDLES TO BUILDING. NOT THE
LEAST OF WHICH IS IMAGINE THE
WORK FORCE THAT WOULD TAKE. WE
DON'T GRADUATE ENOUGH YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY FROM HIGH
SCHOOL THAT ARE QUALIFIED
CARPENTERS PLUMBERS PIPEFITTERS
ELECTRICIANS ARE PREPARED TO
PURSUE CAREERS- THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY ALLOW US. TO BUILD OUR
BRONZE I THINK WE BUILD
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
A HUNDRED THOUSAND HOMES. TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOMES A YEAR
STATEWIDE MISTER GRAYSON MIGHT
KNOW THAT BETTER THAN ME I THINK
HE'S WELL FAMILIAR WITH THAT
INDUSTRY BUT-IT SEEMS ABSURD
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO CATCH UP ON
A TWO MILLION HOME DEFICIT. WERE
BARELY BUILDING ENOUGH IF YOU
WANT TO BUILD A HALF A MILLION
HOMES. A YEAR- IT WOULD TAKE
FOUR TIMES THE WORK FORCE AND
WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH TO TRAIN
THE WORKFORCE AND WE'RE NOT
MAKING- CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS
ANY CHAMBER WE'RE NOT MAKING
BUILDING ANY LESS COMPLICATED
FASTER OR CHEAPER- AND YET WE
STILL KIND OF RECYCLE THE SAME
IDEAS OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN- IN IT YOU KNOW. FROM MY
POINT OF VIEW- NONE OF WHICH
SEEM LIKE THEY'RE IN THE REALM
OF SOLVING ANY OF THE PROBLEMS
SO I'LL LEAVE IT WITH THAT- I
APPLAUD YOUR- INTENTIONS BUT-
DEFINITELY THINK THIS IS THE
WRONG DRECTION- WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE MORE CONVERSATION ABOUT IT
LIKE SAID HEAR YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
THE DO YOU WANT TO HEAR ALL
QUESTIONS. OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
START RESPOND WHATEVER THIS
YEAR'S PROGNOSIS OKAY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMART. SO THIS BILL
CONTEMPLATES ADDING UP TO A
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. CAPITAL
GAINS ON TOP OF THE ALREADY
CAPITAL GAINS CORRECT. SO
SOMEBODY IN THE TOP BRACKET OF
LIKE SAY IN CALIFORNIA 13% AT
THE STATE LEVEL WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO BASICALLY A 38240% CAPITAL
GAINS TAX ON A PROPERTY THAT
THEY BOUGHT AND WRECKED
VERMISCHTES NUMBER YEAH AND THEN
PUT BACK ON THE MARKET WITH THE
EXCEPTION THAT THIS WOULD ALSO
BE EXEMPT FROM SOME OF THE
EXISTING CORPORATE- CAPITAL
GAINS TAX THEY ARE SUBJECT TO
FEDERAL- YOU KNOW. EXCHANGE
LOOPHOLES- IF THE PROPERTY
VALUES OUR PASSPORT SO IN
ADDITION TO THE MYRIAD OF ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
ALREADY- YOU KNOW WE'VE SEEN
THESE CYCLES THESE HOUSING
CYCLES AND IT THIS IS PROBABLY
THE WORST IS IN IN TERMS OF
SUPPLY SIDE. OF HOUSES AND- YOU
KNOW I I'LL I'VE ALSO SEEN
PEOPLE THAT ARE SPECULATING-
LOSE THEIR LIFE SAVINGS- THAT'S
WHY THEY CALL IT SPECULATING
THERE'S THEY'RE GUESSING THAT
IT'S GOING TO GO UP. AND WHEN IT
WHEN THE MARKET IS LIKE IT IS
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT RAPID EQUITY
RISE- A. B. YOU KNOW SURE
THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF PEOPLE
AND THERE'S A WHOLE ECONOMY THAT
LIVES OFF OF THAT BY THE WAY AND
THERE THE WORKERS THERE THEIR
PEOPLE TO GO IN AND- REDO THE
WALLS A REDO THE FLOORING AND
BRING THE HOUSE BACK UP TO. A
LIVABLE CONDITION BASICALLY
BEFORE THE PERSON THAT BOUGHT IT
PUT IT BACK ON THE MARKET AND
HOPEFULLY MAKES ENOUGH TO COVER
WHAT THE DAY SPENT- FIXING THE
HOUSE UP- SO EASY THESE BILLS
ARE A LITTLE SCARY TO ME BECAUSE
I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE TRYING TO
ADJUSTING MARKET ARTIFICIALLY-
WHEN I THINK IT'S BEEN CLEARLY
STATED THE PROBLEM WITH THE
MARKET IS WE HAVE WAY LESS
SUPPLY THEN WE HAVE DEMAND. AND
WE HAVE TO FIX THAT SIDE. AND
THESE THINGS DON'T FIX THAT.
RIGHT WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK- JUST TO CORRECT SOMETHING
THAT- THE OPPOSITION SAID WHICH
IS UP YOU'VE EXEMPTED- OUR OUR
OWNER OWNER OCCUPANTS THAT'S
CORRECT YEAH SO ONE OF THE
THINGS HE OPPOSITION RAISED IS
NOT A CONCERN BUT WHAT ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO OWN ONE OR TWO HOMES-
THE TYPE THAT- HE- MISTER GRAY
MISTER ADAM GRAY THOUGHT.
BROUGHT UP A WOULD THEY BE
ACCEPTED AS WELL OR AS THE
BILL'S IN PRINT- IT WOULD BE
EXEMPTED FOR ANYBODY WHO TAKES
THE HOMEOWNER EXEMPTION- WHICH
OF COURSE IS YOU KNOW IS ONLY
AVAILABLE TO ONE PROPERTY- I
WILL SAY THAT ANNIE I'M
SUFFERING PROPERTIES THAT WE
NEED MORE RENTAL PROPERTIES AS
WELL OR VACANCY RATE IS HORRIBLY
LOW. ESPECIALLY IN SOME MARKETS-
THAT WOULD BE A CHOICE WHEN YOU
ARE ACQUIRING THAT PROPERTY IF
YOU THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HOLD ONTO IT FOR MORE THAN SEVEN
YEARS YOUR YOUR HOME FREE BUT IF
YOUR INTENT IS TO POSSIBLY GET
AN AND- EXTRACT QUICK GAIN OUT
OF THAT. YOU SHOULD BE SUBJECT
TO THIS- COUNTERACTED MANY WHAT
ABOUT THESE FOLKS TO GO AND TAKE
A HOME THAT'S IN TERRIBLE SHAPE
AND THEN FIX IT UP- IN MY
CLOTHES I DID WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT BECAUSE I MET WITH MANY OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED. OKAY SO YOU WOULD
ADDRESS THAT THE OTHER THING
THAT'S BROUGHT UP IN THE
ANALYSIS IS CONCERNED THAT.
PEOPLE WOULD IN FACT KEEP. KEEP
THE HOMES ARE. OFF THE MARKET
FOR SEVEN YEARS POSSIBLY.
PROBABLY RENTING THEM. SO THAT
THEY- BE LIVABLE SEVEN YEARS
FROM NOW. A DECEPTIVE RAISE ANY
CONCERNS FOR YOU. NOT
IMMEDIATELY- I THINK THEIR
PRODUCTS AND CERN'S OVER-
INCREASED CORPORATE OWNERSHIP
FOR PURPOSES A LONG TERM RENTALS
AND THE INFLUENCE AT THAT CAN
HAVE A RENTAL PRICING HOWEVER.
WE NEED RENTAL HOUSING AS WELL
THE VACANCY RATES THAT ARE
HORRIBLY LOW TODAY ARE LARGELY
WHAT IS DRIVING UP THE COST. OF
RENTS AND SO- FOR THE PUPOSES
OF THIS BILL I'M NOT TRYING TO
GET AT THAT. WHAT I AM CONCERNED
ARE IS INDIVIDUAL OR ANY ENTITY
THAT IS ACQUIRING A PROPERTY SAY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS. AND THEN
FLIPPING AT HOME- IMPROVEMENTS
ARE NOT A FOR ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION SHORT TIME LATER.
BECAUSE ALL YOU'RE DOING IS A
RAISING THE PRICE OF THAT SALE
IF YOU SIT ON THAT PROPERTY FOR
SEVEN YEARS. YOU'RE NOT
AFFECTING THE PRICING OF HOMES.
IN THAT REGION OKAY BUT YOU'RE
ALSO NOT OBJECTING TO THE IDEA
THAT. SOMEONE NON COULD BUY IT
TO AVOID THE TAX. AND FOR
SEVENTY AND THEREFORE PUT OR-
NOT TAKE THE HOUSING OFF THE
MARKET. WE NEED RENTAL STOCK AS
WELL OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS- I THINK THAT IS ALL
THE QUESTIONS CAN WE HAVE YOUR-
FINAL WORDS PLEASE MISTER WARD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I HAVE A
LOT OF WORDS AND I WOULD LOVE TO
WORKSHOP THIS MORE IS THAT
CERTAINLY YEAR GOES ON BUT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE MEMBER
COMMENTS AS WELL- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING UP- YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE- CLARITY IN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS IS NOT. INTENDED TO
AFFECT HOMEOWNERS- THAT THERE
IS- RENTAL HOME. RENTAL HOME AND
HOME RENTAL HOME INVESTMENTS ARE
GOOD- BUT TRYING TO EXERCISE A
HOT MARKET TO EXTRACT THE EQUITY
LEAVING THE NEXT HOMEOWNER WITH
AN EVEN HIGHER PRICE TAG IS
AFFECTING US ALL. MISTER CENTER
RECENT ANSWER SOME OF YOUR OTHER
POINTS I AGREE THAT WE NEED TO
DO MORE ON SUPPLY LEGISLATION IN
FACT WE SHOULD CELEBRATE SOME OF
THE BREAKTHROUGHS THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE DID ACHIEVE LAST
SESSION LAST YEAR TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE. FORWARD ON SOME PRODUCTION
RELATED QUESTIONS THAT HAD
PREVIOUSLY- STYMIED- THIS BODY
TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY PASS AND
I KNOW YOU WERE SET PIVOTAL VOTE
AND SOME OF THOSE AS WELL WE
NEED TO BUILD ON TOP OF THAT AS
WELL I DON'T DISAGREE. THE
LARGEST PART THOUGH OF ACQUIRING
SITES FOR DEVELOPERS LARGE COST
OF DEVELOPMENT IS LAND
ACQUISITION. AND SO WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO
FOR- FEES OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REGULATIONS OR LABOR COSTS OR
OTHER ISSUES LET'S NOT LOSE
SIGHT THAT MORE THAN 60% OF THE
TRANSACTION IS FINALLY IN THE
FIRST PLACE. AND I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE IN MY DISTRICT WE HAD A
LARGE PROPERTY THAT WAS SLATED
FOR THREE THOUSAND HOMES IT WAS
PURCHASED IT WAS WRONG LAND WAS
PURCHASED FOR- TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
YEARS LATER IT WAS PURCHASED BY
ANOTHER EQUITY FIRM FOR FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT EQUITY FIRM PASS IT ON TO A
DEVELOPER FOR FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS SO YOU HAD A
2100% GROWTH. JUST IN THE PRICE
OF LAND AND ALL OF THAT IS GOING
TO BE PASSED ON TO THOSE
EVENTUAL RENTERS ARE HOMEOWNERS
SO WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO
GET AROUND SPECULATION SHORT
TERM SPECULATION BECAUSE IT
AFFECTS THE COSTS. OF
DEVELOPMENT NOW SEE THAT THIS
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT IS A
PRESIDENT CAL. I MISS EARLIER
SPECULATION IS HAPPENING
WORLDWIDE. OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE
INSTITUTED A PROPERTY TAX MODEL
JUST LIKE THAT JUST LIKE THIS-
GERMANY NEW ZEALAND CHINA AND
SOME CANADIAN PROVINCES. BECAUSE
THEY SEE THAT THIS CAN ACTUALLY
AFFECT BEHAVIOR- AND THEY PUT
CONTROLS IN PLACE WITH VARYING
TERMS. NOW THE REST OF CANADA
THE UNITED KINGDOM AND OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE STUDYING THE SAME
WITH A SERIOUS INTEREST. ON
ENACTING POLICY AS WE OFTEN TOUT
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD CALIFORNIA. SHOULD BE
EXPLORING THIS AS WELL. I THINK
KNOWLEDGE THIS NEEDS WORK WE
CANNOT ADVERSELY AFFECT SUPPLY
AND PRODUCTION. NEEDS AND WE
pPROPERTY. AND THEIR FEAR
ARGUMENTS THAT HOME IMPROVEMENT
SPECIALIST SOME CALL THEM
FLIPPERS. NEED ACCOUNTING FOR.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS I HOPE TO
WORK ON WITH THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE DISCUSSION OF IT GOT
THERE BUT- THE CENTRAL REVENUE
AND TAXATION QUESTION IS THIS.
SHE WOULD BE USING OUR TAX
POLICY. TO AFFECT A BEHAVIOR
CHANGE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS IS
GREATEST NEED. IS IT WORTHY TO
MOVE FORWARD. THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR MOVE FORD ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY ONE TO BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME ACT. TO GENERATE
APPROXIMATELY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SOURCE TO NEW TAX FOR BUSINESS
REVENUE. HIS PROPOSAL. SEVENTY
ONE MORE CLOSELY LINKS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DOLLARS
SOURCE FROM PERVERSE NEGATIVE
ACTIVITY WHICH IS ARTIFICIALLY
INFLATING. INFLATING HOUSING
PRICING WHICH IN TURN IS CAUSING
MORE PEOPLE TO NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT
TODAY'S- TESTIMONY AS FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY AND I DO
APPRECIATE THIS DISCUSSION I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE WHETHER THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD OR NOT. THE
PLEASE APPRECIATE THIS FOR ALL
OF OUR WORK ON BROADER HOUSING
SOLUTIONS. THE CURRENT
TRAJECTORY OF MARKET FORECAST
SUGGESTS THE HOUSING PRICES WILL
AGAIN RISE BY DOUBLE DIGIT THIS
YEAR. AND INVESTORS SPECULATORS
WILL CONTINUE MAKING UP A
GREATER SHARE OF THESE
PURCHASES. WE WILL BE IN EVEN
MORE DIRE HOUSING CONVERSATIONS
THIS TIME NEXT YEAR IF WE KEEP
DOING WHAT WE'RE DOING. AND
BECAUSE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES CALL
FOR OUTSIDE THE BOX THINKING.
I'M NOT GOING BACK TO MY
CONSTITUENTS TO TELL THEM I
DIDN'T TRY. EVERYTHING THAT I
COULD TO MAKE HOUSING MORE
ATTAINABLE AND I APPRECIATE THIS
QUESTION HERE TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU IN THE YEAR AHEAD. ON
IMPORTANT HOUSING CONVERSATIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR WARD. UP IN THE ABSENCE OF
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR I WAS
ASKED. TO HEAR MR GRAYSON SPELL
. FOR THE RECORD- GRAYSON I'M
SORRY ELECTED GRAY INSTEAD OF
GRAYSON WHERE. 38% YEAH- SHOW ME
GRAYSON ISN'T HERE LET'S LOOK
THE CALL ON THREE BILLS. YEAH ME
UP TO PLEASE FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE CHOI.
LIFTING THE CALL ON AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS GRAY.
GRAIN NOW CALDERON VOTING
CALDERON NOT VOTING. SANTIAGO
SEYARTO I'D SAY OUR TO OUR-
PLEASE REPLACE THE CALL. OKAY WE
PLACE THE CALL OF NEXT BILL IS.
FILE ITEM TO AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE IRWIN. LIFTING THE CON AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
GRAY. GREAT I CALDERON CALDERON
I SANTIAGO SEYARTO NO SERONO.
THE BILL IS OUT CHAIR THAT THEY
WILL LOSE OUT. AND THEN- WE HAVE
AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE WEEKS.
LIFTING THE CALL AND AB TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS GRAY. GREAT I
CALDERON CALDERON I SANTIAGO
SARAH NO SERONO. TWO THREE FOUR.
THE BILL SHOULD BE PLACED ON
CALL IT NEEDS ONE BILL BELLAS
PLACED BACK ON CALL. ALL RIGHT-
ISRAEL WAS ELICITING AND HERE ON
THE VOTE ONLY. ALL RIGHT WE CAN
DO ADD ONS ON THE OTHER BILLS
THERE'S TWO OF THEM. A. B.
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR QUIRK-SILVA
THIS WAS FOR VOTE. ADD ONS FOR
AB TWO OH FIVE FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS GRAY.
GREAT I CALDERON CALDERON I
SANTIAGO SANTO SPIRITO HI. AND
THEN- NUMBER TEN- AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY NINE SANTIAGO. I'M
IN. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
AGAIN YEAH AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
NINE C. AUTO. ATALANTE HER GO
ADD ONS FOR AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE EXCUSE
ME RUSSIAN IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GRAY. GREAT I
CALDERON HI CALDERON I SANTIAGO
SIERRA THEY'RE NOT VOTING. ALL
RIGHT- SO WE NOW HAVE- I WAS A
NOT VOTING ON ITEMS ONE AND TWO
- GOING TO VOTE I ON- I ITEM
ONE- ACTUALLY HAVING A LIVE CALL
HELP LIFT THE CALL ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN. THIRTY NINE CHOI
LIFTING THE CALL AND AB.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE QUIRK I
WORK NOT VOTING TO OUR HIGH TO.
PLEASE RE PLACE THE CALL THE
FIVE REPLACE THE CALL. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR AUTHORS-
MAYBE AUTHORS MISTER GRATION
AND- AND THE CHAIR AND JOB WE'LL
WE'LL GET TO THAT SOME DAY.
ONE THE.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING. YEAH YEAH
THERE'S ONLY ONE OF THE LUCKY
FOR YOU WE'VE GOT. SO I. WILL
HAVE TO FIGURE.
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR AUTHORS
. YES THE- I'M- THE. WHEN MY
MISTER GRAYSON BE ABLE TO COME
BACK WELL MISTER GREECE IS CHAIR
OF A COMPLETE THERE'S ONLY ONE
BILL UP WITH A PRESS ONE ONLY
FILL UP IN THE STREET WHILE- FOR
THESE BILLS SO YOU SHOULD BE
BACK IN FIFTEEN MINUTES OR SO.
WE'RE NOT SURE IF THE IDEA OF
THE COMMITTEE WAS TO ALLOW US TO
BE ABLE TO BE HERE FROM THE
COMMITTEE ORDER. ON THE BILL IS
PRESENTED SO WE'RE NOT SURE WHAT
TIME NOW SO I DON'T I DON'T
WANNA HOLD ANYBODY UP AYE WELL
WE DON'T HAVE THE CHAIR HERE
EITHER AND SHE HAS TO PRESENT A
BILL SO WE'LL WAIT AWHILE
LONGER. FOR MISTER GRATION. IT'S
NOT GOING TO. US. JOHN TOWLE
THIS. IS THERE WHEN IT COMES
BACK WE HAVE PLENTY OF TIME SO I
APPRECIATE OKAY.
FIFTY
GOOD. YEAH JUST.
THIS. YOU WILL. OKAY I HAD. TO
OKAY. MISTER SEA IS HE WE'RE
GOING TO- THE CAR ON BILL'S HAS
NOT ON YET WITH I THINK IS OF
THEM SO LET ME LIFT THE CALL ON
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE CHOI.
PROPERTY TAX TAX DEFAULTED
PROPERTY SALES. BUT YEAH TAKE
YOUR TIME WE'RE NOT IN A RUSH.
GO AHEAD THEN- MADAM SECRETARY.
SANTIAGO ON AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
NINE IT'S ON CALL VOTING
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING. WE WOULD
HAVE TO REPLACE THE COUPLE. ALL
RIGHT REPLACE THE CALL NOW LIFT
THE CALL ON AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE IRWIN INCOME TAX REDDING
RETURNS. I AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE HAS PASSED FOR AN ADD ON
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. WILL CLOSE
THE CALL. I'LL OPEN THE CALL ON
AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE REX
PROPERTY TAX SALES ACCESS TO TAX
DEFAULTED PROPERTY INFORMATION
ON AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS FIGHT
TO SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I- MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT BILL HAS PASSED
THE BILL PASSED- LET ME- CHANGE
MY NOT VOTING TO WIN ON. WE'RE
NOT VOTING TO HI RUN OUT OF
CLOSE THE CALL ON AB TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. NOW OPEN THE CALL ON
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR QUIRK-SILVA
CORPORATE TAXES EXEMPT
ORGANIZATIONS- MADAM SECRETARY
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR AT THAT
BILL HAS PASSED THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATION AS AN ADD
ON SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO THANK.
BY THE CLOSE THE CALL ON A B.
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR AND OPEN IT
ON. AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE
SANTIAGO. THE BILL HAS PASSED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATION AS AN ADD ON
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO. CLOSE THE
CALL. THE BILL IS PASSED- MR
SANTIAGO I HOPE THAT THIS ENDS
UP IN THE BUDGET. YEAH YOUR BILL
IF YOU NEED HELP LET ME KNOW I
WILL THANK YOU ARE. WE ARE STILL
WAITING FOR TO AUTHORS THE CHAIR
AND MISTER GRAYSON AND THEY'LL
GET HERE WHEN THEY GET HERE.
WE'LL JUST WAIT. LOCALS YES YOU
CAN DISAPPEAR THANK YOU. I WILL
CALL. SURE. I'M UP IN KID.
TRANSACTION. OKAY THE GENERAL-
YEAH. YEAH. YEAH YEAH. SO I HAVE
THREE THE- I HAVE READ A THREE
IRWIN. REYES YES YEAH.
OKAY GRAYSON THE MINIMUM. EXCUSE
US. THIS IS. NOT. SO. THE RIGHT. OKAY. THE. IT SHOULD BE HERE.
THIS IS A. HE'S HE'S. FOR AND I
KNOW. THE WORK WORK. CARE ACT OR
OKAY RIGHT. SO. WANT TO PARTNER
WITH. RIGHT NOW I THE ONLY ONE
HERE AND I READ YOUR BILL SO I
NEED TO PRETTY FOR. NOW. AND IT
WAS TALKING TO. RATHER THIS WAY. CRISTINA. OKAY OKAY YEAH. THIS
IS A FOR PERSONAL. WELL YEAH.
YEAH HER- SYSTEMC TO SEE AN ORAL
HELLO AND IT WAS KIND OF. THIS
OKAY SHE.
SHE OKAY. YEAH LIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE. YEAH WORKING WITH.
I SEE. AND YOUR. PRESIDENT TRY.
OKAY SO. OKAY. OKAY. YEAH OKAY
SHOULD THE. AND COULD YOU PLEASE.
DID YOU KNOW. WE YEAH I'M.
ALTHOUGH THIS IS NOT. JUST THANK
. YEAH FIRST. SEVEN BECAUSE-
THEY CABLE BOX. YEAH YEAH. BUT
YEAH. OKAY. I HAVE T. LIKE WHAT
OKAY IS THAT. THIS IS. BUT NO IT
WASN'T. SHE. YEAH.
DO.
EIGHT
OKAY. THANK YOU. FOR THE
GOVERNOR. OKAY THEN YEAH WOW. SO
WITH I HAVE. SO THAT. ONE IN.
OKAY.
THIS YES PRETTY. MADAM CHAIR.
WE'D LIKE YOU TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT PERSONAL INCOME TAXES
CREDIT EMPLOYER QUALIFIED WAGES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MR QUIRK
MMHM DESPITE SOME PROGRESS IN
RECENT DECADES IN TIGHT LABOR
MARKER AT THE TIGHT LABOR MARKET
CURRENTLY INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES STILL EXPERIENCE
UNEMPLOYMENT AND POVERTY RATES
FAR ABOVE NATIONAL AVERAGES
THESE CHALLENGES OF ALL ME BEEN
COMPOUNDED BY THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WHILE
EXPRESSING AN ABILITY AND DESIRE
AND WILLINGNESS TO WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
ECONOMY MANY ADULTS AND YOUTH
WITH DISABILITIES EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL HELP SECURE
AND SUSTAIN QUALITY JOB
PLACEMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES BY
PROVIDING QUALIFYING. EMPLOYERS
WITH A MODEST PERSONAL INCOME
TAX CREDIT THIS INCENTIVE WILL
BREAK THROUGH INTENTION
ENTRENCHED STIGMA AND LEAD TO
FULFILLING AND REWARDING FOR
BOTH EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS
ALIKE. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT R. DAVID LOPEZ WHO WILL
SHARE HIS EXPERIENCE SECURING
EMPLOYMENT TO AND DAVID. AND
DAVID THE GENERAL MANAGER AT
RECYCLING INDUSTRIES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU LEGISLATION HI MY NAME
IS DAVID LOPEZ AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THIS TESTIMONY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE SEVEN EIGHT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND BELIEVE
THAT IT WILL PROVIDE INCREASED
OPPORTUNITY. FOR PEOPLE TO WORK AND EARN
COMPETITIVE WAGE. THIS BILL. IT
DEMONSTRATES THE INVESTMENT OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES BY
PROVIDING EMPLOYERS WITH THE TAX
CREDIT. INCENTIVE WHEN THEY HIRE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. I AM
CURRENTLY COMPETITIVELY EMPLOYED
AND I HAVE I HAVE A DISABILITY
MYSELF. I HAVE WORKED WITH ALL
OF CALIFORNIA REGIONAL CENTER
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
HELPS PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES FOR TWENTY FOUR
YEARS. PROVIDING ADVOCACY
SUPPORTS- TO OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
. AS A MEMBER OF OUR EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT TEAM AS WELL. MY
EMPLOYER STANDS BEHIND
COMPETITIVE AND- INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT BUT- SKEWS ME BUT
THERE ARE MANY EMPLOYERS WHO
DON'T FULLY HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
KNOWING THE VALUE OF HIRING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
PROVIDING AN INCENTIVE TAX
CREDIT SHINES A LIGHT BRIGHTLY-
ON THE POSSIBILITY AND SUPPORTS
INCREASED JOB OPPORTUNITIES JOB
PLACEMENT AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EMPLOYERS TO DISCOVER FIRST HAND
THE BENEFITS- EMPLOYMENTS
EMPLOYMENT IS A GREAT EQUALIZER
FOR PEOPLE WITH WITH THE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ARE
COMPETITIVELY EMPLOYED AND HAVE
INCREASED WAGES WHICH PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ACCESS TO
BETTER HOUING AND MEDICAL CARE
ESPECIALLY IN THESE DAYS. BY
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I BELIEVE
THAT IT WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE- WITH
THIS DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
TO BE ABLE TO WORK AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR COMMUNITY
AND SOCIETY IN MEANINGFUL WAYS.
PLEASE VOTE ON ON AB TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU BOB DO YOU HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS PART YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. YES SIR THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN FOR ALLOW
ME COMMON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S DAVID KUNIN.
I'M THE GENERAL MANAGER OF
RECYCLING INDUSTRIES WHICH IS
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA NORTH HIGHLANDS
BOTH HAVE A PLACE UP IN YUBA
CITY AND I'M FLANK BY MY DAD
BEHIND ME HE STARTED IN OUR
BACKYARD BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND SO HERE WE ARE
ANY WORKS FULL DAYS EIGHTY FIVE
YEARS OLD. SO I JUST WANNA TELL
YOU THAT I THINK THIS BILLS
ASSEMBLY- ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT A GOOD
PROGRAM OUR OUR COMPANY HAS OVER
FIFTY EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR OVER FORTY YEARS.
AND THE BIG WHY HERE IS THAT. IN
OUR INDUSTRY AND RECYCLING WORK.
CALLOSUM DESIGNATES US AS A HIGH
HAZARD INDUSTRY. AND WE HAVE TO
EXPEND. A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
ENGINEERING AND TRAINING AND
EXTRA TIME TO BRING IN PEOPLE TO
CARVE OUT A GOOD SORTING
POSITION. FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DO THAT HOWEVER DOESN'T COME
QUITE EASILY COMES AT A COST SO.
I WOULD SUPPORT ANYTHING THAT
WOULD ALLOW AT LEAST SOME SMALL
LITTLE- CREDIT FOR US. AS WE ARE
WILLING TO TAKE THAT RISK
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT RISK IN
THE IN THE TRAINING TRYING TO
FIND THAT RIGHT FIT BETWEEN THE
PEOPLE ON THE JOB. AND I THINK
THAT TO THE EXTENT YOU CAN
APPROVE THIS BILL AND ALLOW US
TO. KEEP IT. KEEP GOING IN THE
IN THE TRAINING EFFORT EFFORT
AND COMPENSATORS FORD AND
SOMEWHAT SMALL FASHION WHICH I
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS JUST A LITTLE BUT- IT'LL
HELP- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE- BEEN ABLE TO DO IS- YEARS
WE'VE HAD OPPORTUNITIES FOR.
PEOPLE WITH AUTISM TO BE ABLE TO
SORT. SPECIFIC TYPES OF
ELECTRONIC WASTE WE FOUND THAT
WORKING QUITE WELL WITH THAT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE PEOPLE SORTING
GARBAGE OFF OF OUR CARDBOARD
LINE WHICH IS QUITE EASY- AND
IT'S VERY REGIMENTED AND BEEN
VERY FOCUSED. SO THE EXTENT WE
CAN WORK YOU CAN WIND UP. I'M
WIND UP. OR- TIME FOR COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS- SO WITH THAT. I'M
GOING TO ASK QUESTIONS I USUALLY
ASK SO IS THIS INTENDED AS A
REWARD BECAUSE I THINK RATHER
THAN INCENTIVE BECAUSE MOST
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET THIS ARE
PEOPLE WHO EMPLOY OUT LIKE YOUR
RECYCLING CENTER EMPLOYEE THEM
ALREADY AND I JUST- I'M NOT SURE
THAT YOU GET THAT MANY MORE.
PEOPLE EMPLOYING. THERE IS
SOMETHING TO BE SAID FOR
SUBSIDIZING THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
THERE ALREADY SO WHAT IS THE
INTENT OF YOUR BILL. IT REALLY
IS- IN INCENTIVES AND- THAT MADE
FIVE TELL YOU OF A LITTLE BIT OF
THE CONVERSATION THAT I HAD
WITH. A FORMER SENATOR SHE HAD A
SON WHO IS DISABLED AND THERE
WAS A BILL THAT PASSED THE
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THAT- REYES
THE- MINIMUM WAGE FOR. SPECIAL
NEEDS FOLKS AND HER SON LOST HIS
JOB BECAUSE OF IT- SO THERE ARE
MANY EMPLOYERS THAT ARE
OPERATING VERY CLOSE TO THE EDGE
AND REALLY DO HAVE BIG HEARTS
BUT JUST CAN'T QUITE MAKE IT
WITHOUT THAT LITTLE EXTRA
INCENTIVE SO I DO THINK THAT A
LOT MORE EMPLOYERS- WILL LOOK AT
THE ADVANTAGES OF HIRING
SOMEBODY WITH SPECIAL. WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS YOU KNOW NOT ONLY
FOR THE COMPANY BUT ALSO FOR ALL
THE BENEFITS THAT IT GIVES TO
OUR- NO FOR OUR TO OUR SPECIAL
NEEDS POPULATION OKAY AND I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATE YET AS TO WHAT THIS
WOULD COST. WELL I WILL ASK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IS THERE AN
ESTIMATE YET ON THE COST. PLEASE
SHARE- THEN SHARED WE LISTED
THERE IS- ESTIMATE OF- ON THE
ANALYSIS YES WE YEAH- C.
ACTUALLY MIGHT WITNESS POINTED
OUT SEVEN SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
. ANNUALLY WELL DR. THERE IS A
LIMIT ALSO OKAY- I'M SORRY I
SHOULD HAVE ASKED FOR ADD ONS
ADD ON IN SUPPORT. A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND IS THERE
OPPOSITION THAT WISHES TO
TESTIFY. AND THE ANSWER IS NO
ALL RIGHT SO IT'S SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS WELL I HOPE YOU CAN GET
INTO THE BUDGET SO THAT THIS
WILL GET OUT OF APPROPRIATIONS.
I APPRECIATE THAT- MISTER ACTING
CHAIR. YOU THANK YOU VERY ARE
RIGHT- QUESTIONS HAVING BEEN
ANSWERED- I THINK WE ARE NOW
WAITING FOR MR GRAYSON AND FOR
MEMBERS TO RETURN WHO HAVEN'T
VOTED YET. HI. SCANNED SO IF
MISTER GRATION OF MADAM CHAIR OF
MR GRATION IS AUTHORIZED TO
STAFF TO PRESENT SO PERHAPS
THAT'S BEST WE DO THAT NOW. WE
CAN HAVE.
SO ALL RIGHT.
ALL OKAY THE CAN CAN WE HAVE-
THIS RACES ASSEMBLY. AS I'M
WATCHING- MAKING HE LEFT THE
CHURCH SO I'M ASSUMING HE'S
COMING DOWN. OKAY IF HE'S NOT
WITHIN THE NEXT LIKE TO. WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A LITTLE EXTRA
TIME BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE TO BE RESOLVED
SO NO RUSH. I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY STRIVING MARVEL BASED
ON.
PERFECT TIMING I JUST FINISHED.
YEAH SHE TOOK A LONG TIME. THANK
YOU CHAIR FOR BUYING TIME. THE
OUR RIGHTS SO WE HAVE A AB
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE. WHEN EVER
YOU ARE THIS RACES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBER
MEMBERS. THANK YOU DR COURT FOR
STICKING AROUND- BEFORE I BEGIN
THE PRESENTATION I DO WANT TO-
THANK CHAIR IRWIN AND HER CHIEF
CONSULTANTS TO ROUGH. FOR THE
GUIDANCE AS WE WORK TO BRING
SOMETHING BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
THAT ACTUALLY STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN THE NEEDS OF ONE OF OUR
STATE'S ECONOMIC DRIVERS AND THE
NEED TO MAINTAIN FISCAL
PRUDENCE. AS THE ECONOMY
RECOVERS FROM THE RECENT
PANDEMIC I AM YOU TOO ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS LAID OUT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH NARAL
THE BILL TO EXPAND THE TO EXPAND
THE CURRENT EXEMPTION FROM A
PARTIAL EXEMPTION TO A FULL
EXEMPTION REMOVING THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AND A LIMIT ON
PURCHASES ON QUALIFIED PER ON
QUALIFIED PURCHASES. AND INCLUDE
A REPORT BY THE L. A. O. TO
EXAMINE THE IMPACTS OF A FULL
EXEMPTION AB NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
SIX TWO AND SEND LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS SPENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY BY PROVIDING A FULL
SALES AND USE TAX EXEMPTION FOR
PER THIS OF MANUFACTURING
EQUIPMENT THIS WILL FACILITATE
THE GROWTH HIRING. AND TRAINING
OF SKILLED WORK FOR THE FUTURE
PROVIDE WAGE JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIANS PRE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIANS MANUFACTURING
SECTOR HAD ALREADY FACED A
DECLINE IN TOTAL EMPLOYMENT MUCH
OF THIS DECLINE HAS BEEN A
RESULT OF CALIFORNIA'S COST OF
DOING BUSINESS WHICH IS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST IN NATION. COVERT
AND DEMOCRATS FOR THEIR CHILD
CALIFORNIA'S MANUFACTURING. AND
MAR OF TWENTY TWENTY
MANUFACTURING JOBS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE DECREASED BY 4% AND OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAS ATTRACTED LESS THAN 1% OF
THE COUNTRY'S MANUFACTURING
INVESTMENTS WITH OTHER STATES
AGGRESSIVELY ATTEMPTING. TO LURE
OUR STATE'S MANUFACTURES WITH
ATTRACTIVE LOWER BUSINESS COST
AND LOCATION INCENTIVES THIS
BILL WILL HELP TO REVERSE THESE
TRENDS AND MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
ATTRACTIVE TO INVESTMENT.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE FACT
ARE YOU READY THAT THIRTY EIGHT
STATES ALREADY HAVE A FULL SALES
AND USE TAX EXEMPTION FOR
MANUFACTURING EQUIPMENT
PURCHASES AND ON THE FIVE STATES
HAVE NO. HAVE NO SALES TAX- IT
IS IMPERATIVE THE STATE FIND
WAYS TO MITIGATE FINANCIAL
BURDENS PROMOTE INCREASED
PRODUCTION AND ENSURE THE GROWTH
OF HIGH WAGE JOBS. FOR A VARIETY
OF SKILL LEVELS AND BACKGROUNDS
IN ONE OF THE STATE SPEECH
CENTRAL IN HE'S- A STOUT
MANUFACTURING JOB BASE. IS KEY
TO THE GLOBAL AND DOMESTIC
COMPETITIVENESS OF OUR ECONOMY
BECAUSE OF ITS BREATH AND
BECAUSE OF ITS RATING. THERE IS
A MISCONCEPTION THAT ALL
MANUFACTURING IS DONE ON LARGE
INDUSTRIAL SCALES. BUT OVER 70%
OF MANUFACTURERS HAVE LESS THAN
TWENTY EMPLOYEES SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZE MANUFACTURERS FACE A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
ECONOMIC BURDENS INCREASED
CAPITAL COSTS DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. AND WHAT THE HIGHEST
STATE AND LOCAL SALES TAX RATES
IN THE NATION. AB NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE WHAT TO EASE SOME OF THOSE
ECONOMIC BURDENS CALIFORNIA HAS
COMPARE MANUFACTURING ADVANTAGES
TO REGION THE WORLD. DUE TO THE
STRESS AND TO THE DEATH ITS
INPATIENT. BUDGET NOT ONLY DOES
INDUSTRY EMPLOYS ONE POINT THREE
MILLION PEOPLE IN. BUT A- KEY
ROLE IN GETTING THE JOB WITH A
SMALL. AFFECT SUPPORTING TO
POINT FOR JOHN FOR A- MAY. JOB
MANY. PLAYS A CRUCIAL AND
ESSENTIAL ROLE WITHIN OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY SUPPORTING HIGH
WAGE JOBS SMALL BUSINESSES WITH
ROOM FOR GROWTH IT IS MY HOPE
THAT AB NINETEEN FIFTY ONE CAN
BE A TIPPING POINT. TO ENCOURAGE
A NEW IN AN EVENT HERE
MANUFACTURER HERE REALITY BY
PROVIDING COMPANIES TO PLANT
ROOTS IN OUR STATE AND TO GROW
IN OUR STATE WITH THAT. I DO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN THE COMMITTEE TAKES ACTION
ON THIS BILL AND WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY LANCE HASTINGS PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR GRAYSON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
REALLY APPRECIATE THEM TO HAVE
THE BILL HEARD BEFORE YOU TODAY
AND THE- IN ADDITION TO WHAT
EVERYTHING THAT. WE SHARED BY MR
GRAYSON WERE THE FACTS AND
FIGURES ABOUT THE MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRIES WANT TO TAKE A LOOK
BACK TWO YEARS AGO WHEN THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR WAS DEEMED
TO BE ESSENTIAL. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WORKING
THROUGHOUT THOSE TWO YEARS HAS
BEEN RATHER DIFFICULT AND A LOT
OF CAPITAL INVESTMENT WAS
WITHHELD BECAUSE OF THE ANXIETY
ABOUT THE FUTURE THIS BILL WE
FEEL AS A CATALYST TO HAVING
THAT INVESTMENT TAKE PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. AND I'M I
KEPT AWAKE AT NIGHT BY TWO
FIGURES THAT RECENTLY CAME OUT
THE FIRST IS MANUFACTURING JOBS
HAVE GROWN IN SEVENTH PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE JOBSREPORT
THAT JUST CAME OUT FROM LAST
MONTH. THAT REALLY SHOULD BE
FIRST OR SECOND LET ALONE THIRD
THAT WERE RANKED SEVENTH AT THE
MOMENT AND THAT DOESN'T BODE
WELL FOR THE STATE'S ECONOMY THE
OTHER IS MUCH MORE DAUNTING
CALIFORNIA SECURES ONLY 1% OF
ALL MANUFACTURING INVESTMENT IN
THE COUNTRY. JUST 1% THAT MEANS
ALL THE OTHER STATES ARE
LITERALLY EATING OUR LUNCH.
PARTICULAR SPACE. MANUFACTURING
IS IN FACT THE TIP OF THE SPEAR
FOR THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND WE
THINK THIS BILL WOULD ACTUALLY
pIMMEDIATELY BEGAN TO DEMONSTRATE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
SKIN IN THE GAME ALONG WITH US
AND WE LOOK FOR TO BE HERE FOR A
LONG TIME. WE CIRCULATED THE
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS TO ALL OF YOUR
OFFICES LAST WEEK. WE HAVE A
THIRD PARTY ANALYSTS HAVE SAID
THAT THIS BILL WOULD COULD
RESULT IN JOB GROWTH OF A
HUNDRED SIX TREETOP. HOUSE
THAT'S MORE THAN 10% OF THE
CURRENT BASE IN MANUFACTURING
AND ALSO GENERATE THREE TO FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
STATE PRODUCT. SO WE LOOK FOR
TIERED SUPPORT REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT IF THERE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WE'RE JOINED BY CAL
TAX OUR FRIENDS. TODAY IF ANY OF
THEIR ART I WOULD IMAGINE
WORKING MISTER RUFF AND OUR
STAFF. VERY AGGRESSIVELY OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS COUPLE
TO THE STILL MADE NEED
ADDRESSING- RELATED TO USEFUL
LIFE. BUT THIS CONVERSATION WILL
AND HAVE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT AND
I AND I DO A PRE. TO WE WOULD
LIKE ACCOUNTABILITY OF WITH
THESE TYPE OF BILLS SO- GETTING
THE L. A. O.'S REPORT WILL BE.
CRITICAL IN IT YOU KNOW IF THIS
GETS ALL THE WAY THROUGH AND- AT
IN EXTENDING IT SO PRECIADO THAT
YOU- TOOK THAT AMENDMENT THANK
YOU MANAGE- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
I'M JOHN ARMENTA ROBERTS AND I'M
WITH CAL TAX AND WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL I- WORKED
AT PRICEWATERHOUSECOOPERS AND
KPMG AND I WAS AN AUDITOR WITH
THE STATE SIDE I DEALT WITH THE
CURRENT MANUFACTURING EXEMPTION
SO THIS IS. QUITE AN IMPROVEMENT
SO WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT. MICROBES
IN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE GLASS
PACKAGING IS TO WHICH IS THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION OF GLASS
CONTAINER MANUFACTURERS AND
HEARING SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
TWO THOUSAND- HIGHWAY UNION
WORKERS AT THESE CLASS PLANTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND THE
MULTIPLIER INDUSTRIES THAT FEED
THAT INDUSTRY- IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MORE ATOP HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS COUNCIL. AND BIO CALM
CALIFORNIA I WAS ALSO ASKED IF I
COULD REGISTER SUPPORT FROM
ADVAMED AND- WE ARE HAPPY TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR BREAK LET
THE TO WITH APEX GROUP ON BEHALF
OF SOLAR TURBINES DOING BUSINESS
ACTUALLY HOLDEN SAYS SUBSIDIARY
AT AS OF. EXCUSE ME OF A
CATERPILLAR IN SUPPORT. PORTION
MIDDLETON HERE IN SUPPORT WITH
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES. THANK
YOU PRESTON YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN SUPPORT. KAREN LAYING ON
BEHALF OF THE SPECIALTY
EQUIPMENT MARKET ASSOCIATION OR
SEMA HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
ROSA ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AT YOUR NUMBERS
CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH CORBIN IN
KEIZER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
POSITION THANK YOU. NECRO ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
EXPRESSING CONCERNS AND HOPING
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
RIGHT THANK YOU A QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUICKLY YES SO ARE IN THE
FIRST PART WHAT YOU'RE DOING ON
YOUR MAKE YOUR MAJOR CHANGE. IS
THAT THE CITY AND COUNTY SALES
TAX. WOULD NO LONGER GO TO THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND THAT'S
WHAT MAKES IT. WHICH IS GOOD
BECAUSE IF IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE
STATE BUDGET YOU WON'T HAVE AS
MUCH TROUBLE APPROPRIATIONS. ON
THE OTHER HAND THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES ALMOST ALWAYS SUBJECT
TO THAT BUT THEY DIDN'T PUT IN A
LETTER TO OBJECTIVE YOU WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THEM WE ARE MAKING
AN EFFORT TO WORK WITH OUR
LOCALS- COMING FROM LOCAL
MYSELF. SO WE ARE MAKING AN
EFFORT TRYING TO- WORK OUT
CONVERSATIONS AND I KNOW THAT-
OUR SPONSORS WORKING HEAVILY AS
WELL IN THAT AREA SO IT'S SO
WEIRD WE ARE COMPLETELY OPEN TO
IDEAS AND COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS. TO CONTINUALLY MAKE%
THIS BILL BETTER ALL RIGHT THE
ONE THING THAT WILL HURT YOU AND
APPROPRIATIONS IS LIFTING THAT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR LIMIT
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WOULD
COST US. BUT USED PARTICULARLY
TALKED ABOUT SPOKE ABOUT- SO
BUSINESS. RAISING THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION WOULD HELP. WITH
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE TESLA OTHER
LARGER BUSINESSES. WHY DID YOU
PARTICULARLY BRING THAT FORWARD
. THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION- YOU
KNOW LONGER LIMIT THE- AMOUNT
PAID TO A SINGLE TAXPAYER TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION RIGHT AND I
WANTED YOU PARTICULARLY BRING
THAT FORWARD BECAUSE THAT'S
GOING TO HELP MAJOR BUSINESSES
YOU TALKED A LOT ABOUT SMALLER
BUSINESS CORRECT AND AGAIN THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WAS BORN OUT
OF CONVERSATION AND NEGOTIATIONS
AND- WOULD CONSTANTLY BE OPEN TO
WORKING FURTHER NEGOTIATIONS. TO
PERFECT THE BILL YEAH THAT'S
FROM THING THAT YOU'LL HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE PROCREATION
ABSOLUTELY YEAH OKAY THAT'S
GREAT THANK YOU DR KIRK. AT THE
MINUTE MAYBE MISTER HASTINGS YOU
HAVE A COMMENT ON THE WHAT THE
NEED WAS FOR THE- YEAH. FROM THE
MANUFACTURER'S POINT IF YOU NEED
A SECTOR WIDE BUT IT DOES SKEW
MORE TOWARD THE SMALLER
MANUFACTURERS WHO HAVE WITHHELD
INVESTMENTS FOR TWO YEARS AND
THE WORKING WITH OLDER
EQUIPMENT. AND WE'VE WE FEEL
THAT THE SPURS REALLY GOING TO
TAKE PLACE IN THAT PART OF IT AS
MISTER GRAYSON STATED THERE MORE
MANUFACTURES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE SMALL MEDIUM AND LARGE WE
JUST HAPPENED RECOGNIZE THE ONCE
THE BRAND NAMES THAT WERE
FAMILIAR WITH. THAT OF THE
THIRTY THOUSAND MANUFACTURES IN
THE STATE OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ARE SMALL TO MEDIUM
SIZED BUT WHAT ABOUT THE NEED TO
RAISE THE- TWO HUNDRED MILLION
CAP WELL WE'D LIKE O BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO AS MANY AS
WE POSSIBLY CAN TO SPUR THAT
INVESTMENT SO. TO HER MILLIONS
OF. HE DIDN'T EVEN SAY THIS BUT
THAT'S A SMALL AMOUNT. OKAY ALL
RIGHT I'VE- OKAY- THANK YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
RESPECTFULLY WHAT YES ACTUALLY I
DO HAVE A FEW COMMENTS
MANUFACTURERS WANT TO PARTNER
WITH THE STATE GOVERNMENT TO
REACH CALIFORNIA'S BOLD
LEADERSHIP GOALS NCLUDING
CARBON NEUTRALITY A SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMY AND RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE ENERGY BUT
MANUFACTURERS ESPECIALLY SMALL
ONES ARE HAMPERED IN THEIR
ABILITY TO BE PART OF THAT
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
COST OF SCALING UP PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA. SO AB NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE IS UNIQUELY DESIGNED TO SEND
A SERIOUS SIGNAL TO COMPANIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR COST COMPETITIVE
REASONS TO SCALE UP PRODUCTION
THAT THEY CAN COMPETE HERE AND I
KNOW FIRST HAND HAVING BEEN
CONTACTED BY- AN AUTO
MANUFACTURER OUT OF EUROPE THAT
WAS LOOKING AT THE EAST COAST
UNTIL THEY SAW THIS BILL AND
THEY HAVE SENSE RECONVENED AND
STARTED TO INCLUDE INTO THEIR
DISCUSSION- MOVING TO THE U. S.
IN CONSIDERING THE WEST COAST-
BASED ON ON- THE MOVEMENT OF
THIS BILL SO IT IS GARNERING
GLOBAL ATTENTION. THAT'S WHAT WE
LIKE TO HEAR. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU. SIR. HI
I WOULD LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE CHOI HAS
FILLED A AND THAT IS THREE THREE
AND THEN I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ASK MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
ANNOUNCE THE OUTCOME OF THE- THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA. I AM NUMBER
TWO AB. EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE.
THE MOTION WAS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND THE BILL HAS
PASSED ON A VOTE OF EIGHT TO ONE
. AS TO ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE MOTION WAS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
THAT BILL HAS PASSED ON A VOTE
OF SEVENTY TWO. AS TO ITEM NINE
AB TWO OH FIVE FOR. HE MOTION
WAS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
THE BILL HAS PASSED ON A VOTE OF
ELEVEN TO ZERO. AS TO ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
NINE. THE MOTION WAS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND THAT BILL HAS
PASSED ON A VOTE OF TEN TO ZERO
. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WITH THAT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.